in a new story from project veritas a
whistleblower comes forward with emails
showing that pfizer doesn't want people
to know that they are using fetal cells
in the manufacturing of the vaccine
now we do know that many vaccines have
used in the production of the vaccine
fetal cells they use them to replicate
the viruses
there are i'm not i don't i believe
they're not in the vaccines themselves
but most reporting we have this from the
children's hospital philadelphia says
that it's just the johnson and johnson
vaccine and other more traditional
vaccines but we've seen many pundits say
that the pfizer mrna vaccine does not
use fetal cells well now we know they do
it's a big deal for people who have
religious exemptions and who are upset
about this and i think the other
interesting thing about the story is
that pfizer knows it will be bad for
them and their
capitalistic agenda i suppose if people
become aware that they use fetal tissue
we have a bunch of other stories as well
sweden finland denmark are suspending
use of the modern vaccine over
myocarditis fears and there is a major
shortage of like everything and food
prices are through the roof so
oh man we got a lot to talk about but uh
fortunately somehow i guess the last
minute i get a text message that james
o'keefe is coming to my house and i'm
just like we what what's happening so
james is here hello thanks for coming
man great to be here you got a big story
and we'll we'll get into all of it i
think pretty sure everybody knows who
you are but you are um you are someone
with a a very serious back disorder you
were born with two spines
one of the few remaining actual
investigative journalists and uh
shane who is also here who is uh running
you're running for the governor of
georgia as a libertarian correct
uh we were just discussing how um you
must have uh i mean you're you're
barking up the tree of a lot of very
powerful and wealthy individuals and i
can't imagine that
is uh
well i don't know it's not
nerve-wracking
are you worried
i i try not to make decisions based upon
fear
although you know we're all afraid but
uh
i try not to let fear govern my
all right man well thanks for coming
great to see you
do you want to briefly introduce
yourself yeah pleasure to be here thank
you guys super excited i mean to to be
here with i mean
told me james was coming in on top of
this thing today i was just like oh my
god she's gonna be amazing but uh yeah
i'm the libertarian that's
quote unquote spoil the georgia race for
the republicans down there without
spending a dime and um you know whether
you're talking to republicans or
democrats they they all hate or love me
and i wasn't even in the final race but
yeah uh i run the show radical and uh
man i'll tell you what i'm just i'm
psyched to be able to do this kind of
stuff with you know really i mean i look
around this room right now and i see
guys you know 40ish maybe and they're
changing the world it's absolutely i'm
35. okay same
you got to take off that hat sometime
brother
it's part of the show that's right we
got luke owski's hanging out i think the
shirt i'm wearing is very appropriate
for today's discussion it has mark
zuckerberg saying i delete your post
bezos saying i delete your books
wizinski saying i delete your videos and
of course mr bill gates saying i delete
you which
you can exclusively get on
thebestpoliticoshorts.com and i also
released videos almost daily on
youtube.com forward slash we are change
so thanks for having me we also got
lydia press on the button that's right
i'm along for this ride and it's gonna
be wild tonight i'm super excited to
have james he always has good stories
and shane is fascinating running as a
libertarian so i'm looking forward to
have what they both have to say tonight
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have a bonus members only segment coming
up it usually drops around 11 or so p.m
and with your support we are doing a
bunch of amazing things we got a couple
non-profits that are in the works fact
checking the fact checkers and also
building unbanable social media
technology that anyone can implement
using fetiverse network and a bunch of
really cool stuff so you'll also get an
ad free experience and of course the
members-only content so don't forget to
like share subscribe all that good stuff
we're gonna we're just gonna get into it
because um you know this is what just
it's it's a wild night let me just let
me just start by saying that you know we
originally booked shane to come on the
show and you know just talk about the
news and stuff and then i get a text
message because you know james just
dropped this this very big story about a
whistleblower coming out from pfizer and
we were like okay i guess we're going to
just throw this thing together but uh
just to i guess not mince any words do
you want to tell us what this story is
about and yeah this is a a whistleblower
current employee at pfizer
melissa is her name and she and she uh
took screenshots of some emails from
executives advisor including vanessa
gellman senior director worldwide
research and in these emails the
pharmaceutical executives say quote
one or more cell lines with an origin
that can be traced back to human fetal
tissue has been used in laboratory tests
associated with the vaccine program now
some of this is public knowledge in that
the fetal cells are used but what's
interesting about these emails is that
all these executives at pfizer are
saying to each other let's not tell
people
that that's true
and i'm going to quote the email here
quote we want to avoid having the
information on fetal cells floating out
there we want to avoid uh this is a
direct quote the risk of communicating
this right now outweighs any potential
benefit we see
and they say to hide this information
public so investigative reporting is
always about making public what people
want to keep secret so my question is
why
are these pharmaceutical executives in
their emails trying so hard to keep this
information secret and this outraged the
whistleblower so much
that this woman went public yesterday
night with project veritas on the record
she's currently employed by pfizer
probably the first time anyone has ever
done this sort of exposed the
pharmaceutical industry everyone says i
should be worried about this but i
this whistleblower has informed me that
a lot of people at pfizer agree with her
and we're looking forward to more pfizer
employees coming out now here's the
interesting thing we have this uh i
pulled this up earlier in the day on a
different segment children's hospital
philadelphia that says vaccine
ingredients fetal cells and all of these
there's a whole bunch of articles that
are like certified fact checks say no no
no there's no fetal cells in the
vaccines don't worry about right no the
issue is they use them in manufacturing
or the testing of the vaccine so you're
not getting injected with it but in
order to make them to do the tests they
are using them now there's a couple
really interesting things as it relates
to your story the first thing is this
website from the children's hospital
philadelphia mentions that the jansen
vaccine the jnj vaccine does
use uh viruses grown in fetal cells but
that's the only one it doesn't mention
pfizer so i don't think we had any
confirmation that pfizer was actually
using fetal cells we do have states and
i'm reading from a count the state of
california says quote
pfizer does not require the use of any
fetal cells in order to manufacture
produce the vaccine so this would be a
direct contradiction what the executives
yep go ahead well in the manufacture of
this this this was in the lab tests
laboratory tests yes so that that's
that's that's what i'm saying i feel
like you know one of the things i
mentioned to people
earlier in the day was
we're going to end up seeing a
congressional hearing we're going to get
some republican going like what's this
project veritas report i hear where
you're using fetal cell tissues in the
production of this vaccine and they'll
say we do not use any fetal cells in any
capacity manufacturing vaccine it is
fake news they're online conspiracies
oh we did do tests using them to get to
the point where we could make the
vaccine laboratory tests right so what
you're saying is they're going to sort
of do a non-sequitur and say well we
don't use it to put it in the vaccine
that goes in your body but two things
can be true they can use it in
laboratory tests and also not use it in
the in the uh and they'll and they'll
twist it so right i imagine this you'll
get some a rand paul whatever being like
we have a report from veritas that
laboratory tests in the production of
the vaccine and they'll change the
subject exactly right change something
and say we do not manufacture the
vaccine with fetal cells that's not true
and then when the republican
if any of the republicans actually do
question this will either miss the
manipulation or not have enough time to
follow up and that's the political game
they'll play so i do that's particularly
fascinating but i will add to on top of
all of that just from this article from
chop.edu when they mention why they use
fetal cells this is what that really got
me they said it's because fetal cells
can typically divide more times than any
other cells they say uh in fetal cells
it is around 50 divisions they can make
other cells can only can divide
substantially less because they're older
cells
so it sounds to me like it would just be
an inconvenience to use cells that
aren't from aborted fetal tissue but
they're making a cost-effective decision
that it's cheaper and more effective
right and and uh this is another quote
from the email here from vanessa gilman
senior director worldwide research these
are not low-level
employees tim sometimes we get
criticized for going after mid-level no
these are these are high-level people
here vanessa gilman saying quote general
members of the public who may take this
information and use it in ways we may
not want it out there avoid raising this
as possible what's interesting about
these pfizer emails is they also talk
about facebook they say we don't want
this information on facebook
which is deeply ironic given all the
censorship occurring about our videos
are being taken off facebook so these
executives are so concerned about people
knowing this information that the
cells are used in the development of the
vaccine
man it just makes me feel like um our
our these massive multinational
corporations elements from the
government big tech
they know the re that the masses the
populous opposes this stuff they know
they have reason to fear if people hear
about this they'll object to it they
know what they're doing violates the
morals and ethics of regular people and
so they're like just don't let them know
about it yep just hide it from them and
and uh but the good news the silver
lining in all this in this dystopian
reality is that uh i find that you know
when i met with you a year ago we talked
about this vision to manifest you know
hundreds of whistleblowers these days
they're all i mean i'm talking tens of
thousands of people have messaged me in
the last few weeks so it's all happening
it's happening um because there's no
place else for them to go and and it's
getting worse and worse that that
divergence between reality and what's
presented on cnn it's just that that's
getting wider of a gap seeing the people
chanting let's go brandon all over the
place
yeah i mean i know it's a funny thing
but
these are regular people at a jets game
at a football game
just take a look at what is the uh the
fountain documentary that's coming out
on disney right i mean and you see the
trailer for it on youtube and it's got i
don't know seven thousand thumbs up and
it's got 75 000 disapproval thumbs down
like that's a really good moment for
people in america who are like yeah you
know what maybe we should be talking
about mandates versus you know
absolutely
the government not having this power
yeah i think we have to be careful we
talked about the other day about getting
wrapped up into like discussions about
exemptions because we should be just
saying no man it's period yep because i
think i think the the any argument that
says there are some mandates that are
some okay some of the times as long as
we have exemptions results in a social
credit system
but you know
well in my opinion the vaccine passport
um is not going to lead to a social
credit score because it already is a
social credit score it's already the
score of compliance that people have to
jump through they know that there's
going to be a third one they know that's
going to be a fourth one and there's not
even a conversation when this is going
to end usually with the lockdown usually
with a policy that's very intrusive in
our lives the government comes out and
says we're going to end this after this
many people uh you know die from covet
after these many cases we don't have any
of that we don't have any conversation
to when this will end when this will
stop and it's not going to stop that's
the new afghanistan yeah that's the
thing is there's no mission there's
never been a mission over there that i
mean what we've been talking about with
the afghan papers for what 20 years
right no mission we're still sending
guys outside the wire it's a
never-ending mission and this is the
same thing it's like there is no end in
sight
i i think the the the the big issue here
is uh with with james's story
you've got a lot of people who have
filed for religious exemptions and
they've been denied now first and
foremost like i said we'll be careful i
want to make sure we're very clear we
should be saying outright no vaccine
mandates period regardless we shouldn't
be demanding papers it's between the
person and their doctor if you want to
go and seek medical help it's between
you and your doctor not us here on the
internet or your business or the
government
now you have uh you know government
officials and businesses with no with no
regard for your private health matters
and on top of that
imagine you're in new york city where
they mandate this and you've got some
embarrassing medical condition and now
you've got to go around every business
exposing this embarrassing condition
that should be private matter for you to
live your life with dignity that's
another reason why i'm just like they're
demanding ids at the door that being
said
this is i think a lawsuit winner for
people who have religion who want to
assert religious exemptions yeah and
there's no religious exemptions at
pfizer for that's what this insider came
forward regarding so i think it's a game
changer for society it's just we live in
this dystopian reality where these facts
are just not even accepted i mean things
have changed so quickly even since i
last saw you i mean uh in in a just
world this would be on the front page of
the new york times and on 60 minutes
these are executive emails advisor yeah
you know what
i'm pretty sure everyone else was pissed
off equally as much by the same thing
when you see the fake whistleblower from
facebook and not a single whistleblower
that veritas has come out with is going
to be propped up on 16 minutes and given
this airtime right that was uh the
morgan common at facebook blew the
whistle on the vaccine hesitantly scores
and he responded to blumenthal from
connecticut saying there should be more
people inside tech but the whistleblower
inside facebook the supposed
whistleblower wanted more censorship
i mean not even that i mean look at
assange look at snowden i mean these
people are still in exiles assange is in
jail his accuser who lied about
the main witness that the government had
against him was caught lying he was just
arrested in iceland just moments ago and
assange is still in jail how does that
make sense it doesn't power yeah those
are the real whistleblowers and then
there's whistleblowers that work towards
the agenda and the narrative that of
course they keep and they prompt they
make prominent uh number one news
articles on cnn that they promote
non-stop uh i really wanted to talk to
you james specifically because i know
you've got deleted a whole bunch of
places i tried to share your video on
twitter today yeah and it said you're
spreading disinformation i'm like wait
what i clicked on the link and it gave
me some
rambling jumbling nonsense that didn't
even address the claims you were making
right but but you couldn't like it you
couldn't comment right you couldn't do
anything about it so how has it been
using alternatives how have your numbers
uh have your numbers dwindled have your
numbers got higher how's the fight with
online censorship because they're going
after you pretty hard well uh and eric's
in the room with me i mean we've gotten
the most watched views ever
and i'm i'm i'm we've trended on twitter
think of think of this think of it
i've trended on twitter and veritas has
shown on twitter for each and every
story we've broke and i'm banned from
twitter and i'm suing twitter
you can't make that [ __ ] up
the reason why is because of
distribution by proxy so it doesn't
matter like if i get banned and he gets
banned and the third guy will upload the
video and i i text message a click to
tweet link like i i sent to you
and and you can click on it and it'll
embed the video populate now they'll try
to censor it and do things but um for
the most part they haven't taken me down
i have actually uh sent a letter to mark
zuckerberg this week saying please do
ban me i want you to ban me
um cut my tongue out of my mouth on the
eve of the release of the whistleblower
and it'll only make people want to tune
in to see what they have to say so i'm
leaning into the censorship i'm willing
to lose everything and i think you have
to be but every video that we've done
eric is in the room he's he's the guy
who who does social media with veritas
um every video we've done has gotten
millions of views on youtube and on
twitter over the last few releases
so um i'm hopeful as long as the content
is strong enough and true now i'm not
opining on the vaccine i'm not even
going to tell you my opinion about it
i'm just showing facts
and because i've sued the new york times
and sued twitter and sued cnn there's a
part of me that feels these companies
are actually afraid of me
uh by violating their own rules by by
crossing some rubicon they haven't yet
crossed so so far yes they'll add the
little tags and advertisements under the
video
but they haven't taken us down yeah i
remember it was very difficult to share
your video and i was just wondering you
know what's going to happen from here
but seeing all the alternatives seeing a
lot of different platforms jump up
seeing all the individual people kind of
rise up seeing the 75 000 dislikes on
the dr fauci documentary seeing the
chants everywhere i mean how can you not
have hope and and when the reality gets
so skewed on the mainstream media by the
government by the by the corporations
where literally joe biden was claiming
that the unvaccinated are the ones
putting the economy at risk today that
was literally what he was saying
something interesting happened to me uh
a lot of people were posting that when
they tried to put the link up to the
story they were getting warnings on
facebook have you seen that yes we've
all i've seen i wish i had these
messages in front of me i've seen all
types of weird in fact eric one of the
it seems like they were actually
manufacturing custom messages just for
me
it's like
so nice and it used to be able to ratio
people on twitter right so right so we
have you know 600 000 people on telegram
so if i just post the url of the guy on
twitter like making some boneheaded
comment ticket ratio twitter disabled
people from doing that now you can't
ratio people so they're they're
customizing the interface so that you
you're not allowed they're trying to
hide it
did you know that uh there's a website
tracking likes and dislikes on joe
biden's videos showing that they erase
dislikes
but but here's what i was gonna say so
whenever i hear that there's censorship
on facebook i immediately i'm like all
right try me and i don't know i've had
no problem posting the the stories on
facebook they've not been deleted enough
again
no warnings facebook is
really sweet here here's one russell
brandon blue check mark um project
veritas is taking the exciting leap from
mostly harmless [ __ ] to [ __ ]
that will actively cause people to die
so i i sent this url to 500 000 people
but if you go to his twitter page you
can't comment on him unless russell
brandon is mentioned so they're taking
steps to eliminate this but again it
wasn't my claim i'm quoting pfizer
executives you understand the
distinction like i'm not opining about
what i think about about the virus or
about emails in writing i'm quoting
their vice president saying we must lie
to the people we must deceive the people
this is this is a
the law of non-contradiction you
shouldn't lie to people whether you're
left right republican democrat it
doesn't you shouldn't lie
i was actually just talking to sean
spicer on newsmax about uh they edited
joe biden's comments because he made the
snide comment where like you know when
cinema gets harassed doesn't happen to
people with secret service
and uh and and so he's saying
nbc reports this comment but they cut
out that part
so you don't get the full context it's
deceptively edited my immediate reaction
was like oh i love it they deceptively
edit their videos and then they can
write all day about how james o'keefe is
doing that when he's showing you people
literally say things in a conversation
oh i have one quick story luke about
something you said about censorship so
one of the things they do which i know
you're familiar with is they use these
fact checkers you know like fact check
or experts say story has been debunked i
love that one experts say it's like
imagine if you're someone who walks on
in on you cheating on your wife you say
i'm sorry honey experts say this has
been debunked
[Laughter]
but anyways the the usa today
um what they do is they're they work
with facebook to do a fact check right
so they can put out a piece
that's used to justify to get your thing
banned on facebook so facebook can say
well experts say usa today so yesterday
called me tim after the first
video the the hhs was to blow on our
series two weeks ago and i said oh here
we go again
usa today is setting this up so i don't
know what to do because no matter what i
say it doesn't matter they've already
written their article they're just
asking me for comment
so what i did is i called usa today and
i recorded myself
leaving a voicemail for usa today and
then i distributed my comment to usa
today to everyone
preempting them saying if you don't
publish my comment i will sue you
usa today did not put out the article
whoa and then facebook didn't take the
article down so i think the way to
preempt communists the way to because
we're dealing with this let's call it
what it is communism the way to preempt
communists
is to publicly announce what they're
going to do record yourself giving the
comment
ever hear world i'm i'm giving my
comment to usa here is my comment if you
don't publish this i'm going to sue you
and they know i'm not bluffing
so usa today didn't publish
that article and facebook didn't take us
down it's it's what we mentioned before
about um you know in a previous segment
we're just talking about uh congress
questioning someone from you know pfizer
about fetal tissues the fact checkers do
the same game they someone will make an
assertion and then the fact checkers
will take a similar but different claim
to make it sound like they're debunking
the claim so next thing you know we're
going to see snope saying are fetal you
know the claim a project veritas story
releases a bombshell people are now
saying xena yes yes non-psychological
non-sequitur it's it's a it's not it's
not so much that they're lying it's that
they're it's the logical non-sequitur
it's the fallacious logic they change
the subject and then and then there's
this game of telephone and before you
know it o'keefe made a claim that i did
not make that claim that's brilliant
that's the funniest thing about i think
almost all of the work you do is when
you put these videos out you're not
saying i believe in this policy and that
policy and i voted for bush like none of
those things happen right they'll
they'll make the they'll it's a straw
man argument effectively is what it is
can you can you guys just see wikipedia
already
uh we're working on it uh we're gonna
sue the users on wikipedia and since i
last saw you as you know we defeated the
new york times motion to dismiss the new
york times
appealed that tried to issue an
emergency stay so we couldn't depose
them we defeated their emergency stay so
we're we're getting pretty far in our
lawsuit obviously the wheels of justice
turn slowly
but um i think it has deterred them tim
from from lying how you you launched
that thing recently the the defense fund
i think uh yes project veritas legal
organization which is under our 501c3 it
was your idea actually the people's
defamation defense fund we just named it
project veritas legal nice so you stole
my id and renamed it
either way it's it's amazing that that's
happening we need more of that and i
would say what you're doing is is not
even controversial it's just journalism
it's what journalism used to be a lot of
journalism of what we see right now is
literally regurgitating what the power
structure says
and then saying now do this you don't
even tell people what to do uh i mean
you have your own personal opinions you
you have your own biases everyone has
their own biases but there's a big
distinction between what we're seeing in
the mainstream media and what we're
seeing with alternative media what we're
seeing with you and i think we need more
of that more than ever um and then i'm
just trying to think of other ways maybe
we could help facilitate that or get
involved i think journalism is is
reluctant to get into an exposed
position where they're seeing as
affecting events
and rather than just reporting to them
and traditionally there was always this
adversarial nature to journalism but
these days like you say they only print
the established line they only are
allowed to publish what they're told on
the record in fact
quote unquote journalists wait to see
what the corporation has to say and only
when they've given give been given
permission to to report the thing do
they report the thing it's become so
much worse even in the last couple years
they don't publish anything that's not
the established public line cnn's health
advisor just came out today and said los
angeles has just invoked some of the
strictest vaccine policies in the united
states excellent this needs to spread
everywhere that's not journalism that's
that's
hiring a lunatic yes sociopathic crazy
person that wants to enforce their will
onto you journalism is about letting
people hear the story letting them know
decide themselves letting them see the
evidence and then just leaving it there
for the viewer to decide what is right
for them informed consent something that
again needs to come back more than ever
and and i would say we don't have any of
it i don't think i think these people
are so fundamentally unaligned even on
the first amendment these days and and
there's this great uh reporter named
david shaw who wrote i'm a great
believer and the reporter as an observer
firsthand observation is the old
ultimate documentation almost every big
story that we do
we often have to impersonate someone in
order to have the first hand observation
of the thing happening that's what
investigative journalism does
you use whistleblowers you go undercover
et cetera et cetera so this is the
perversion the perversion i've seen is
that they won't
say
anything unless the corporation or
government official tells them you're
allowed to say this we we've had uh
several segments talking about the
reporting you've done and wikipedia yeah
so when i pull up the wikipedia it's
horrible
oh it's beyond it
it's it's insane it's uh but i'm gonna
read some because it's important they
say project veritas is an american far
right activist group founded by james
o'keefe the group produces deceptively
edited videos of its undercover
operations which use secret recordings
in an effort to discredit mainstream
media organizations and progressive
groups
project veritas also uses entrapment to
generate bad publicity for its targets
and has propagated disinformation and
conspiracy theories in its videos and
operations now there's a couple things i
want to say
all of the citations on this are opinion
pieces yes
yes wikipedia is an encyclopedia it says
yeah this whole article has taken random
opinions and it was funny because i was
looking at the talk section on wikipedia
where the editors talk and someone said
why are we using all of these op-eds
it's not it's not what was the response
to that guy oh they get shut down in two
seconds
but you want to know this is why i just
said to you i want you to sue wikipedia
because there's something very important
right above that that paragraph i just
read yeah it says from wikipedia
oh it doesn't say from usercatlover42
it doesn't say from johnnybgod900 it
doesn't say from we are change it says
from wikipedia right here they banned me
on wikipedia so i'm not on there
it says
what do you mean from wikipedia
it says at the top of the site project
veritas from wikipedia the free
encyclopedia project veritas is
if they're asserting the statements have
come from themselves that's a good point
it doesn't matter so i'll put it this
way
we launched timcast.com we got a bunch
of users it's going really well we have
journalists
could i take random comments from users
quote block the text and then put it in
an article that says from tim cast or
from tim poole right and then assert oh
it's user generated content we're 230
protected
no i've put my byline on it wikipedia
has asserted this is their statements
from them yes now if they can they can
remove that but i think as as long as
that exists and they have asserted this
on this page about veritas nowhere does
it say the statements came from any
journalists any writers any pundits
opinion people or users it only says
from wikipedia i i think that's a great
fact i will talk to my lawyers about
that but i do intend to sue wikipedia in
some way matter shape or form
and i will do that whether it's the
users the website will do it but it's
very important your audience understand
this i know you do you said they're all
citing opinion pieces and and that in
the new york times lawsuit tim the new
york state supreme court judge actually
said how deceptive it was for the new
york times reporter to mask uh a f's
first sentence of the article and
defended it saying that's my opinion and
that was deceptive and that was
disinformation the judge actually said
it was disinformation for the new york
times to call it an opinion when it was
used
to justify all types of other things but
they use supposition they use circular
sources this is the way the propaganda
works i admire these writers on
wikipedia and the new york times you
have to be an artist
to to paint reality in the way that they
do
it's it's any any time i aim a camera in
any direction it will contradict what
you see
on that page and that's why people are
so pissed off that's why the
whistleblowers are coming out because
listen people are going to give up their
livelihoods right now
i've spent my whole life effectively
doing this since i was in college for
you know 15 16 years and you might have
one or two people a year that say okay
i'll do it right now 10 000 people are
willing to do it
that's the silver lining people are
waking up and sometimes maybe it has to
be darkest before the you know the light
you know when i was looking at the uh
the pfizer scientists video you did it
some of them seemed like that one guy i
think his name was nick carl right yep
and he seemed like he he was reveling in
it yeah mandated do it but one of those
guys i think the guy's name was chris or
whatever seemed kind of like
i know what's going on is bad yeah i'm
not a fan of this
but they're not willing to
nobody wants to nobody wants to stick
their neck out nobody wants to take the
responsibility of what it means that
they're a snowflake contributing to this
avalanche yeah we talked about this last
time it takes a lot of courage to stick
your neck out but in the 20th century
people didn't really have
as many options and and these days that
you know you can put a go you know not
go funny because they banned us on
gofundme
give son go raising half a million
dollars for whistleblower half a million
dollars for whistleblower now at project
veritas i i'd say i think what like 10
years ago that was that was near
retirement funds but now with inflation
through the room
and one more comment i want to make
about how journalism has changed i'm
seeing this a new phenomenon occur the
mainstream media will now not reveal
newsworthy information due to the quote
harm
the information might inflict on the
subject exposed remember the communist
teacher thing we did a month ago
gabrielle gaip in california with the
com
oh yeah yeah cameron sickle yeah this
guy was saying we you know talking about
child abuse and we need to scare scare
the f out of kids and a lot of the
people in sacramento had to report on
this because he was fired so they had to
report the news
but one of the refrains was they're not
going to mention the name of the teacher
listen to this quote teacher whose name
we are not disclosing
due to a potential harm against him wow
so this is a new phenomenon in
journalism we're not going to reveal
news with information because the person
might be harmed same thing with the fbi
or you know these his parents might it
might do harm to the teachers well well
actually this is fascinating one of the
core journalistic ethics is minimize
harm right but they only are now
applying it you take a look at cnn when
they were like here's the name of the
man who posted the nancy pelosi video
here's where he works right maximizing
harm against those who speak out against
their political ideology in this
instance we're not going to reveal who
this person is i'll give you a really
really good example of how this is is
manipulative in the mainstream press and
you know
he goes out and he reports on antifa
violence and extremism he he goes on
twitter and he posts photos of the
people arrested at these extremist
events the left says he's making kill
lists he's secretly working with the far
right and then their allies in media
regurgitate the lies ryan reilly of the
huffington post has been doing
literally the exact same thing about the
january 6 defendants they cheer him on
as an intrepid and amazing journalist
doing the good good work of exposing the
extremists as far as i'm concerned both
of them are doing journalism by saying
here's the guy who was charged here's
why he was charged i'm fine with either
but you can see how the political
ideologies and you can see how the
mainstream media is willing to support
one
and oppose the other that's the murder
cult you can't attack the murder cold
and that's the thing is like you look at
everyday regular people and their
businesses their homes their property
their livelihoods
the government doesn't care about that
oh they've been decimated but if you go
after those guys on the shiny white
capitol hill you invade their space and
let's face it like those guys they got
more ammunition and and firepower in
their trucks that they left behind and
they didn't bring in there and
like the fbi said there was no there was
no plan there's been a bunch of raucous
people who rioted it was bad like we all
yeah okay it was bad it's not cool yeah
i mean but that you know
you have now stories that um they don't
track the leftist violence in the same
way they do the right you have the
hearings about how the right is
substantially worse this is the
fascinating thing i'm kind of i want to
loop this back to how they they frame uh
on wikipedia a far right what does that
even mean when they don't know it's i
beside myself like i said in the
beginning of my in the beginning of my i
guess career i used to fret and have
sort of ptsd over the wikipedia page
i've come to accept it
the moment you stop giving a [ __ ] about
what they think of you and stop seeking
their approval is the moment when you
become truly free
i've learned this in my life it's just i
have to accept the unacceptable i to be
labeled far right
i i literally don't express my opinion
in any i've never expressed my opinion
in any of the investigations i've ever
done and all they do on television is
express their opinion i don't see
anything but them express their opinion
it's it's orwell's uh you know 1984
double thing well at least you haven't
been unpersoned uh on wikipedia they
they literally on person why did they do
that because i was exposing the russian
hoax right when it was uh the most
prominent in the mainstream media they
were saying there's clear russian
collusion russia hacked the election
they helped donald trump win and i'm
like no no no that didn't happen where's
the evidence we don't see any evidence i
don't believe in this story and because
of that wikipedia there was some editor
that wrote well even though they do
newsworthy stuff like get on epstein's
island or talk to this politician or
talk to this whistleblower we're going
gonna refrain from even naming them in
any future wikipedia entries uh and i
was like wait what i was like who's this
random user i forgot the user's name but
just completely unpursued me from
wikipedia i don't even exist on that
platform the last time i looked so
there's many different ways that they
try to go after you a lot of times they
try to silence you a lot of times they
attack you and i think they have to use
both because they know if they just
attack they sometimes make people grow
as well right they don't want to
mentions like voldemort right mario they
can't mention us by name or you know so
uh i i mean far right i i don't
and of course there's probably like how
many uh citations footnotes
one two three four five six seven eight
nine there's like all these opinion
pieces they're citing after that word
wikipedia
have you seen the uh larry sanger we had
him on the show once he was one of the
he's one of the co-founders of wikipedia
and he has just left his prop again at
this point it's crazy i used to donate
to wikipedia i was such a big fan this
idea of the community coming together
and being like let's get some good
reliable sources but i'll tell you this
even uh it's fascinating to me
when i look at media matters for
instance media matters is literally an
activist organization i mean i'm not
exaggerating or trying to insult them
they're an organization that scours
right-wing content or whatever you want
to call it and then disparages them
they've made they've made up things on
numerous occasions and newsguard which
is i believe funded by microsoft is uh
their their green green checkmark all
good all good speaking of media matters
this is a matter's headline last week
youtube is taking a victory lap for its
latest vaccine misinformation policy
meanwhile project veritas is gaining
millions of views on youtube
for quoting people uh so so media
matters is doing the yeoman's work of
trying to get us banned for doing
investigative reporting i i think you
should sue newsguard newsguard yeah
so we use newsguard specifically because
i consider it a check on our bias
these are so newsguard is a fact check
it's a rating agency
they they have a 10 point system uh 100
point system and veritas has a 57 out of
100 in their scoring system they say the
website fails to adhere to several basic
journalistic standards which are those
they say you do not gather and present
information responsibly you not handle
the difference between news and opinion
responsibly really you don't disclose
owner ownership and financing and you
don't provide the names of your creators
along with either contact or biography
how do they erase this
big propagandas right
that's what i wrote
you know what's funny i've never lost a
lawsuit project veritas has won every
single lawsuit and i will give ten
thousand dollars to any human being who
can name one deceptive edit in the last
decade of my life no one can do it but
they just keep saying i doctor tapes i
mean it's it's
i
it's become so cliche to say 1984. it it
doesn't even mean anything anymore but
it's like the double thing you know to
tell deliberate lies while genuinely
believing them to forget any fact that
becomes inconvenient and to draw it back
from oblivion when it becomes necessary
to do so to deny the existence of
objective reality it is what they do
and i
i keep saying this it's just pissing
everyone off such that there's going to
be an uprising here here's how it works
luke and i are sitting here
i report
uh
there is a court rose quartz crystal
ball here on the table right luke then
reports you know tim poole is lying it's
actually a fluorite crystal ball what
happens then is you as the fact checker
can say either one of us is the liar
depending on which idea you want to
support so when i'm looking at the news
guard for ver for veritas you they
mentioned that you featured a postal
worker named richard hopkins right now
you actually did a story where he made
claims where he said things that's right
and you reported those things that's
right the mainstream media then called
you a liar they've decided the
mainstream media's claims are more valid
than yours thus you're not telling the
truth when they're literally trying to
decide between two people who made a
statement
just to say a word about that that
postal worker richard hopkins the
washington post
um uh richard hopkins was interrogated
by
federal agents and richard hopkins we
had a recording of his interrogation we
published the recording
and then somehow the washington post was
leaked
statements by the federal agents well
there's only two federal agents in the
room and i know they're both of their
names and this and the federal agents
made claims that contradicted the
recording and the washington post
reports anonymously sourced the people
in the room
so they say and then cnn said well
credible sources say and i said well i
have the damn recording
i have the recording rock rock beat
scissors
i have the recording well but then and
jacob age of the of cnn literally you
could see the condescending smugness in
his face when he goes on anderson cooper
and says credible sources like the
washington well i have a recording of
what transpired so they're credible by
virtue of their own decree that they are
indeed credible it's a self-anointed
racket so this this this needs to go in
front of a judge is what i'm saying when
newsguard now says you are not credible
because the washington post has has has
with anonymous sources challenged your
actual recordings it needs to get it to
a judge where the judge can determine is
this is is this defamation or is this is
this liable it's written we in day i i
was just uh emailing my colleague this
and we did indeed send a demand for a
correction to um newsguard to peggy
ackerman senior editor at newsguard and
we're in process of that and and tim i
have to sue a lot of people i know i've
been suing i mean i'm suing twitter cnn
new york times and we're winning you
know all the lawsuits it's just
like i i think that luke your idea
people's defamation defense fund there
needs to be a hundred people suing the
new york times for defamation we've got
to find the right plaintiffs the right
set of facts to get past motion to
dismiss which is a very difficult burden
to get past uh tim but
i i agree with you and i i will sue
newsguard if they don't um if they don't
uh correct we are entering a new era of
dystopian bs check out the story we got
from axios google and youtube will
prohibit ads on monet and monetization
on climate denial content
look i i i just we've talked about this
with chris martinson
i think you know at least i genuinely
believe we've got very serious
environmental crises on this planet
climate change dead zones fishery
collapse pacific garbage gyre all that
stuff
but man is it a messed up world when
they are coming out right telling you
that there is no the internet it's no
more
you are a pleb you are never supposed to
be given the ability to speak to the
megaphone and they're going to be taking
that away regardless of whether you're
right or wrong
now it's also important to note here are
they stopping people from climate change
denier or stopping people who are
calling out a lot of the hypocrisy and
the climate change movement because
there's a lot of hypocrisy see it's very
vague generalized language that gets
bastardized and abused so much because
again the rules aren't really that clear
on youtube we don't know the exact
parameters we don't know the exact words
sometimes you say the magic special
words your videos get taken down without
even an explanation sometimes my videos
just get taken down just like yours tim
uh without even a notice without even a
notification so so with stuff like that
happening seeing the spectrum just being
broadened like now it's this and now
it's this and now it's that like where
do you end where do you even start we
don't i mean if you're going to give
guidelines give clear guidelines let's
give let's leave let's give clear
protocols if you deny this
specific
uh assessment or argument i mean that in
itself is anti-scientific you should be
able to argue you should be able to have
a conversation and if you can't question
the science it's not science it's
propaganda
and i think people need to realize that
more than ever they can't control people
that way and that's the problem is this
this isn't meant for debate this isn't
meant for us to sit here and have a
reasonable conversation this is meant to
silence people and control people that's
it's this is the state this has always
been the state centralization is if we
can control the narrative we can control
what is said and we can control the
people and at the end of the day that's
what the state does it centralizes power
and it controls people i think they've
lost control i think the
heavy-handedness we're seeing in the
federal government the desperate
maneuvers they're making is just a sign
that
they are they're desperately trying to
assert they have control but more and
more just expose the ampersand that
we're in negotiations do you think this
is like mostly brought on by the
invention of blockchain in immutable
content and social media no i think the
internet in general it was it was a
ticking time bomb that you know they
used to control the flow of information
perfectly you had a handful of channels
where information could come from if you
were a journalist the big story they'd
look at you and say nah we're not
interested
now you have the ability to go online
and like james with telegram put out a
message where people can just click the
link and then it goes up on other social
media platforms yeah i think we're
building our own audience veritas for
the first time i mean that's that's what
strikes me is a
i think this is an age where the loss of
one's twitter twitter account is treated
like the loss of one's life
but there's no i i'm not getting any
coverage on these stories but
everyone's coming to veritas to be
informed that's a new phenomenon so in
the past my
model was to try to get local news
outlets to cover these stories but the
pharmaceutical industry you kidding me
there's actually one local tv station in
kansas
that may cover it only because that's
where the plant where the woman works
and they have to
but um i think there's this phenomenon
where our audience aren't necessarily
fox news viewers tim neither are yours
um so it's just a new audience we're
informing people one by one and then
another thing i get is well nothing's
going to change nothing ever happens to
these people like a cynicism
and i've said this to um a couple people
i said well listen you got to start
somewhere you change one life you can
change the whole world you can convince
a few people you can make a big
difference but i think the phenomenon
with project veritas is that we're
building this new audience of people who
are being informed because it's
incontrovertible videotaped evidence
it's not my opinion it's
incontrovertible while the machine is
very clearly clamping down on what is
acceptable language they are clearly
violating the good spirit of section 230
they're they're setting forth editorial
guidelines
that's what it is when they tell you
your opinion is not allowed to be spoken
they're saying here are the editorial
guidelines of this platform well it's
even questions and i mean that's what it
gets down to is you can you may not make
statements you may just be asking
questions like hey what about solar you
know solar in space weather do we ever
talk about the the solar energy that's
coming out of the sun in terms of its
fluctuations we never talk about that do
we have an answer for what the ideal
temperature of earth is nobody can
answer that it's been decades and
decades and decades since i was a kid i
mean i remember them talking about a
coming ice age in the 80s and thinking
oh my god you know i was terrified and
that was the thing it was like it was
like live in fear live in fear live in
fear no matter what it was and listen as
a conservationist listen i know very
well that when we look at
the the earth we should be living in
more of a balance but this cry for like
the the balance in the ecosystem and
this i don't know this this idea that we
can not say some things about you know
climate change well this cry comes from
a lot of people who live in cities which
have
absolutely destroyed the natural
environment take a i i think back to you
know 20 or so years ago where where was
the right they absolutely denied climate
change right
now they typically accept climate change
but say you know we don't they don't
believe it's man-made or there are
arguments about the solutions by the
left or wrong one by one at a time the
arguments from the right veer leftward
as time goes on
there's no there's no uh the republican
party isn't actually making demands of
the legislature repealing things for
instance i've had conservatives say to
me well look we're not gonna do it the
left does and force the government to do
things
repeal laws repeal the nfa how about
that one they don't do that either why
not
i don't know because they're uh uh
they're the unit party and the
controlled opposition yeah yeah mitch
mcconnell goes i'm going to hold off the
democrats for about two weeks and then
agree with them
and that's what happens he says i'm
fighting with the democrats and then two
weeks later he goes okay we've come to
an agreement
and people keep voting for the guy they
just wait for the next major news story
ramp it up to 10 and then leave it i
believe and genuinely feel a lot of the
people in the republican party have
stockholm syndrome and secretly want to
be liked by the
by the people that they're supposedly
against like i mean i don't know maybe
they want their book reviewed by the new
york times they want to play on their
turf they secretly wish they were at
that met gala with aoc they want to be
there they wish they were part of that
crowd i really do i think that's the
problem they want to be liked they care
more about the opinion of the new york
times and their own kids yes yes and the
moment you stop caring is when you can
actually have the will to win and be
effective but that's a psychological
issue a hurdle for people who are not
part of the so-called mainstream power
structure it's hard even for me i mean
i've i've you know gotten my desire for
approval down to a microscopic
you know bead but
you get more approval because you'd have
to be a sociopath to want to be hated by
everybody but if you want to do the
things that you're proposing you're
going to be hated by
a lot of people who have the power to
make you liked and i and i have to be
prepared to lose i mean i i just passed
a million followers on instagram this
week um and i mean on youtube
we went from 1 million to 1.25 million
subs in like no time and i see your gold
plaque they have not sent me one of
those gold blacks yet
i never got mine
it's sitting in bubble wrap
don't send that out to veritas hold on
hold on here's what i'll do so when you
get those awards those gold and silver
awards yeah they allow you to do a team
purchase so if multiple people work on
your team you can order a custom award
with any name on it from the company so
i think i think i think good good old
team members project veritas and we are
change are going to be getting you know
their their their awards i just think
it's funny that we have 1.3 mil subs and
and our gold plaque is sitting in the
bevel wrap room
at google in california it's like
sitting half open like the manager is
like well you know let's not let's just
verify that those 1.3 million subs are
all real people it's under some some
footnote you know but um listen i think
that the bottom line is i've come to see
it over and over this is my mantra today
the moment you stop giving a [ __ ] is and
seeking their approval is the moment
you're free to actually be effective you
have to not care at the first line on
your wikipedia says far-right criminal
doctors tapes it hurts but you just
gotta let it go because if you do the
thing that you're proposing you're
running for office aren't you yeah god
bless you i'm never gonna run for office
but we need good people so thank you i
hope you're successful in your efforts
you have to not give a [ __ ] yeah what
they think you just have to do the right
thing
and have a leap of faith and a lot one
of the things that struck me about the
hhs whistleblower and the um pfizer
whistleblower is i asked them aren't you
afraid of going after pfizer and they
both said effectively i put my faith in
in god not in man
and whether you're a religious person or
not they're taking a leap of faith
they're saying everything's going to be
okay i'm going to do the right thing
damn it
and i just think that that's what people
need to do if they're going to want to
change things i i 99.9 agree with you on
what you said about not caring but i'm
gonna offer up a little a little
different uh go ahead
see i do care what they write on my
wikipedia because for a long time they
claimed on wikipedia that i invented a
live streaming zeppelin i don't
understand why they think i tim poole
and i was working with drones that i get
and i think one of my live streaming
what zeppelin would be like a blimp
like they claimed i had a blimp why
would they want straight from germany
i don't know and it was in my wikipedia
for like for years is that supposed to
be defamatory
no no but here's the funny thing here's
the funny thing i am so fed up with like
when i read your wikipedia i'm like that
is obviously crazy listen even if it was
true they're opinion pieces that don't
tell us what your organization is and
i'm sick of it so here's what i'm doing
here's what we are doing
after a few years of them claiming that
i invented some kind of zeppelin
and me saying publicly like guys i did
not do this please remove it they're
like you're not a credible source you
can't be used
they finally took it out and i said you
know what i'm going to do now i'm
actually going to invent the damn thing
so they'll have to put it back in i'll
retroactively make their so that that's
the game i'm playing so we actually have
it we have them the zeppelin is near
completion and we're going to be
launching it we're going to pilot with
certification and we are going to have
the live streaming zeppelin and then
they're gonna have to go back and change
the whole thing all over again because
now it's true now it's brilliant
i can't wait to see that i want to be a
part of that
but james you brought up a very
important point and if i could kind of
surmise it a little bit it would be that
words only have power when you give them
power and i think we're really seeing a
lot of crazy ridiculous words out there
to the point where everyone's laughing
at the establishment i mean wolf blitzer
he he posted this photo of himself and
he looks like a geriatrics bald eagle
and he is and he wrote he wrote this
caption nine months ago he's behind the
us capital quote nine months ago today
on january 6th
2021 an angry mob attacked the u.s
capitol i walked around the complex
today and it was very calm as you know
the perimeter security fence is gone at
least for now you know
you know they were getting ratios
the they were calling it fort pelosi up
there oh wow oh yeah good for them it's
ridiculous but you're you're absolutely
right james you've got to be able to
stand on your own two feet and say i
don't care what they say about me if
you're going to be effective in changing
the culture which is the most important
thing that we're up against right now
you've got to be able to sit there and
say listen they're going to tell lies
they're going to disperse me they're
going to blackball me whatever it is you
got to be okay most people when that
happens they stop they they they start
reacting they start playing on the turf
of the of the opposition
and and to do this you effectively do
have to suffer you have to
uh
struggle and and and suffer and and go
through pain
and that's what it's going to take pain
i think i think people are going to go
through a lot of pain
uh in order to get to the destination
but the problem i find i've seen people
do this and then they get lawyered up
and then they start to you know you know
you just got to keep going you just have
to keep i mean we're banned on twitter i
want to tell you we are banned on
twitter
but we're trending on twitter
and it actually renders people get
pretty confused by that they don't
understand it well it's because we you
got to get the stories to be so strong
that nobody can ignore it and we
distribute by proxy so we send the the
stories to other people and they embed
the videos and that's what you have to
do and also i think people have to see i
think images
are transformative and and you say luke
the power of words you know orwell
writes in 1984 the party communist tell
you to reject the evidence of your own
eyes and ears it's their final most
essential commandment that's their
number one rule do not believe what you
see in here so i think words are are not
one
thousandth the power of images exactly
if we're gonna if we're gonna win this
battle it has to be through images
that's why we call it veritas cinema
verite images
anesthetize they they they transfix
in a way that words do not and
oftentimes you're putting that person in
this in this dichotomy in brooklyn we
had we had left-wing people in brooklyn
sharing our pfizer videos i got messages
from people like hipsters were sharing
our videos they didn't even know like
what project veritas was they're just
like wow this big bad pharmaceutical
company is lying to people that's what
i'm talking about you know you guys also
just had a big exposure like a nursing
home scandal that's right in washington
state yeah and um i saw a lot of
sentiment people were saying it's a
bummer this story doesn't get as much
play because it's not culture war but
it's one of the most serious issues
happens all the time in nursing homes
people forge you know check mark
documents a lot of paperwork in the
bureaucracy so people were just forging
uh check marks to take care of these
elderly people they were not providing
care for this is what i love they say
far right and it's like you've got
stories targeting mainstream media and
big tech companies as well as nursing
homes and i'm like are what do you what
does that mean are nursing homes
secretly communist organizations yeah
and you mentioned fear i thought that
was such an important point we should do
a whole hour on fear
because
the guy at cnn
charlie chester said fear sells well
they put the ticker on the screen with
all the people dying he goes we want we
want to be higher i'm quoting him why
isn't it higher why can't we have the
death toll higher from kovid because
it'll sell more ads this is what this
man is saying i hate to be the history
buff in in the room with the
anti-federals they call them the bug
bears and the hobgoblins and the mo has
been the same ever since like the the
anti-federalists sit there and they're
profits talking about the united states
constitution right like this is a
centralization of power and what it's
going to lead to is the enslavement of
every man woman and child in the united
states right like what we should be
doing is keeping these states as free as
possible and you know hey in in peace
we'll be friendly and in war hey we're
enemies but this is what it is this is
what goes into
everything that we do overseas i'm i
mean
former marine uh you know served in the
special operations and and saw this
stuff up close and personal and what
goes into warfare before you actually go
kinetic is a
mountain a mountain of fear and division
and if you can fear you make people
fearful and divide them you can conquer
them and that it's just the the absolute
truth but to see you know what we're
seeing now with these people pushing
fear 24 7 ramping it up i mean do you
guys understand like when we talk about
the 95 or 99.5 percent that they're
talking about in terms of being like
hospitalized in terms of covid or dying
of covid right now what they're talking
about is the cdc number that you're not
actually a
fully vast person until 15 days after
your second vaccination so anybody in
that time that has any type of ailment
that goes to the hospital or dies during
that time that's had a shot or two shots
is considered unvaccinated and that's a
number that they're reporting to you to
scare the hell out of you let's talk
about what fear leads to so we have this
story from the atlantic america is
running out of everything the global
supply chain is slowing down at the very
moment when americans are demanding that
it go into overdrive for the longest
time they said the economy's actually
recovering there's just too much demand
now they're back to actually yeah it's
collapsing now what happens is in the
early days we they said 15 days to slow
the spread and people said okay 15 days
i'm fine with that then they started
saying look at the numbers look at the
numbers cnn i don't think it's a grand
conspiracy i think what happens is cnn
knows it's gangbusters in the ratings
when they get that ticker on the screen
showing dead people regular people then
panic put on 80 masks and are sitting in
the streets shaking and convulsing in
fear they then demand their politicians
the democrats then just then say this is
an excellent opportunity to ram through
our agenda so it becomes this
endless spiral that results in now
nearly two years
of economic collapse and there's no food
to eat i mean there's food to eat but
it's it's expensive i went to the store
today
we got
our i've been talking about this for a
while because we go grocery shopping
periodically our shopping cart was about
three quarters full seven hundred
dollars
i went i asked the i looked at the final
bill it was like 680 something and i was
just like what though
and we have meat cheese you know uh we
got strawberries and i'm like we didn't
like fill this cart i asked the the
woman
our food price is going up and she just
looks me and she goes they are way up
and this is because people are trapped
in a spiral of fear
they're so terrified there was this poll
that went around asking democrats and
republicans what percent of people with
cove are hospitalized republicans
correctly answered it's between like one
and five percent the democrats thought
it was like 40 or some ridiculously high
number why they watch cnn so i'll tell
you when you say like what happens
before a total breakdown or revolution
people don't eat the system is failing
them they have they don't feel secure in
their health you've got a pandemic they
don't feel secure in their homes the
eviction moratorium is canceled they
can't work and they don't have food to
eat
the economy is shut down
this i believe
is first and foremost a fault of the
media who was willing to lie cheat and
steal to drum up their ratings because
they've been dying for the past several
years we heard it from shane smith the
ceo of vice back in 2014 he said there
will be a bloodbath in digital he was
talking about how media was going to be
on fire and it was coming soon we then
started seeing the ratings collapse and
we still do of all of these big networks
but then trump came along pumped some
lifeblood in the system for a little bit
now that he's out and the ratings are
collapsing once again they are desperate
what do they got put that big old death
number on the screen because it'll shock
people and get us ratings but those
scared people vote for for
authoritarians and despots who then
choke out the system causing a further
collapse it is a downward death spiral
and we're trapped in it well said yeah i
mean i was talking about this earlier
today i mean i i think we're at war and
this is you know i don't say that
lightly and i've always been this person
that's super optimistic but when i look
at what the landscape is in the tactics
and procedures that i've seen in other
countries you've got mass confusion
through propaganda misinformation
disinformation you've got the economy
and the supply chain being destroyed on
purpose by these people i mean they they
went after all the small businesses this
last year where you see banks you see
corporations and you see politicians
making out like bandits but anybody
who's not in that upper echelon they're
getting screwed you've got the ramp up
of government assistance because things
are failing and people need to eat they
need to clothe themselves you see the
mandates for medical tyranny happen in
germany you've got the creation of food
shortages in a place where food is
abundant i mean everybody's seeing the
damn dunkin donuts video right where
we're just throwing out trays and trays
and donuts right like not that donuts
are going to be you know your staple but
we throw out food and that's a great
problem to have in a country you also
have the
instigation of riots you have the sowing
of hate and discontent you have the
silencing of descent these have already
happened in america what you're missing
is the removal of assistance or the
centralization of this assistance where
you say hey listen we can't take care of
you out there anymore you're going to
have to come here into this camp you
know it's a i know far-fetched idea and
yeah but look at uh do you guys you see
what's happening in australia right
you're building camps well now we have a
story from the daily beast that said
fascist anti-vaccine mandate rioters
caused you know outbreak of covid and i
said that's what they were going to do
next i said they built the camps and
they say it's just for the people who
are traveling yeah then you're going to
see protests over their draconian
mandate and then they're going to say oh
no they caused a super spreader event
for their own good they'll need to be
quarantined i have the article here
actually lined up as you were talking
about it and the article is titled quote
fascist anti-vaxx riot sparks covet
outbreak in australia with rupert
murdoch's help yeah i mean
talking about just living in another
reality i mean holy freaking cow this is
the the same magazine that was the same
alleged news organization that was
cheering on the blm protesters that that
were making arguments that scientists
say blm protests help people with covid
and help prevent the spread but
anti-vaxx protests somehow spread the
spread how does that make sense there's
no logic here there's no understanding
there's a completely different world
that people are living in and that's
right no no no no no no stop watching
the news well no no no i i do think a
lot of them have to lie to themselves
have to convince themselves i do believe
there's psychological warfare out there
i do believe there's a lot of people
under trauma-based mind control because
non-stop what was just
issued into their head is everyone's
dying your grandma's going to die your
mother's going to die your loved one's
going to die that has such an impact on
you and they were locked down inside of
their homes and told to watch the the
boob tube and what happens you're
literally linked into the programming of
the multinational corporate elites that
are run by big pharma agencies that are
invested heavily in it that are
regurgitating everything to the point
where people are just blindly repeating
it and in such a trauma state to their
shaking uh in their boots at people
walking near them that's the point that
we're at right now and it's delusion
pfizer uh incorporated on twitter uh
this is uh today we're in a race to save
the world we've teamed up with the daily
beast they're teaming up sweet and we're
going to put this teaming so so pfizer
right here
pfizer incorporated this is a blue check
mark pfizer on twitter we're we're
teaming up with the journalism
organization what do you mean teaming up
with investors are they just are they
just supposed to report
there's this symbiotic
massive multinational pharmaceutical
joins forces with me journalists
i mean
quotation marks but like it's all about
the fear yeah it's all about the fear
and like
in some small way like when we got the
pfizer scientist on monday saying oh you
don't need a vaccine if you've had covet
your antibodies are stronger if you've
had cove you don't don't take our
vaccines this is a scientist a master's
degree in neurosurgeon
biology
i was shocked to find how wrong the
pfizer scientist was as we all know
right that physical scientist certainly
was giving the incorrect stated opinions
yeah well there were three of them
saying the same thing it's not weird now
that means those three scientists who
are clearly wrong
should not be working for pfizer
i mean i mean the editorial guidelines
of youtube are clear and this is how you
keep your stuff up on youtube
well look if the scientists said them
we're not saying it they can say
whatever they want but that's that's
that's what i said i see yeah yeah the
the joke is if youtube is saying you
know uh you can't say certain things
about the vaccine that literally the
scientists believe yeah then how can you
have a mainstream narrative
like asserted by youtube that the
scientists at fire at least three of
them don't even agree with clearly then
they must be wrong i guess right you
know we're we're um i've said this
repeatedly my colleagues were in the
room with me i was with laura logan in
texas she said something really struck
me she said that we are at the gates of
auschwitz right now the gates of
auschwitz
and uh she said the coup has already
occurred
you you said it eloquently luke did you
did tim i mean everyone did it and the
only thing that's preventing the gates
from opening the proverbial auschwitz
the modern day version of that whatever
that looks like you know
like the tom cruise movie oblivion where
he goes up in the spaceship and the
world is controlled by this monolithic
who knows what that looks like
but she said the only thing that's
stopping us from entering the gates is
we the people it because there are so
many good people out there i i guess i
see it so much because i get so many dms
and emails like thousands and thousands
and thousands of people are so pissed
off
and i and this is america i mean this is
not these other places in the past
this is america and i think when people
are pressed against the wall
i just feel like they're just not going
to take it they're not going to what are
your fellow
marines
it's a great place to bring this in
because we had you know obviously the
collapse of the afghanistan withdrawal
right all completely planned by the way
i mean when we talk about like what's
going on with these people who are
standing in
patience right now and i really like for
your audience maybe they haven't heard
this but i think america has been
extremely patient because they are
powerful and you can be quiet and
powerful and you can stand in power and
not sit there and say hey listen we have
to do something violent we have to be
you know we don't have to be you know
peaceful like we
we are a peaceful people 99.9 of people
go about their everyday life without
hurting people without robbing them
raping them murdering kidnapping
whatever america and most people are
extremely good patient people if they
wanted to do something about this it
would be over in a blink of an eye
especially given the amount of
combat hardened veterans that we have in
this country i i
i don't think we're headed towards a
place of like mass civil war type
violence i don't either if if people
didn't want to do something they need
only just carry on with their lives yeah
that's the thing right if texas is upset
with new york they don't agree with each
other and then texas just says we're
going to do our thing you do yours
what's the issue why would anyone
complain so right right now i think the
big issue is
the so there's a story i keep harping on
about 10 violations issued in new york
city over the uh business vaccine
mandates 10
10 out of how many thousands tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
businesses they have no real ability to
enforce this
they issued warnings
several thousand warnings over not
having signs in their stores but the
reality is if people in new york just
said i didn't i don't care there would
be no vaccine mandate well and i'll tell
you you know i've started this thing
called the helios initiative and at
first it was i'm going to talk to
anybody and everybody in the liberty
space that's running for governor and
then it translated into well hey listen
we're a post-constitutional republic now
we're acting through executive fiat and
orders and everything else we have the
judicial that's backing them up and we
have a spineless
relegated congress and legislative
branch
how do we sit here and say hey listen at
the local level how do we change this
reach out and touch your elected sheriff
and reach out and touch your elected
mayors who control the local police
force if you can do those two things and
i'm doing it locally in my county now
because one of my very good friends and
my jiu jitsu instructor was pulled over
driving well black and a 2021 lincoln
navigator and there was nothing wrong
with the car it was a it was a
dealership hand-me-over so that they
could work on his and when this happened
i said hey man you know to the to the
mayor and the chief of police the chief
police ended up hanging up on me and so
i took it to the mayor he's a other he's
a marine and i said hey this civil asset
forfeiture deal that you guys are doing
around here is absolute nonsense and
i've laid it out for him you know per
the constitution the mechanics and how
it works you can't change the
constitution without an article five and
all of anybody who's ever in a office
for government swears an oath per
article 6 section 3 of the constitution
and anything that's not pursuant to the
constitution per article 6 section 2 of
the constitution is
of no pursuance of the constitution and
is void so if you can sit there and say
hey listen locally we can touch our
mayors we can touch the sheriffs and we
can say this is not going to happen in
our counties or in our cities you can
start to affect real change
but if the state can't steal where will
it get its money
perfect but i also wanted to kind of
highlight uh the lockdowns because i
think they're far more significant than
we even led on to because after 9 11 you
couldn't avoid just non-stop
establishment mainstream media news
reporting about what happened the trauma
of it and there was a lot of
psychological warfare there
something very similar happened where
you couldn't avoid anything surrounding
the the sickness covet that was going
around during these two weeks of
lockdowns it's just two weeks to stop
the spread people were told to stop
working they were told to shut down
their businesses they went home they
went online they turned on the
television and everywhere they went you
couldn't avoid this thing and the
mainstream media the elites the the
bureaucrats the government officials the
multinational corporations were able to
talk to them directly and i think they
did
cause
not just economic destruction and a lot
of mainstream media talks about it's
it's coveted that's creating this
economic havoc no no no no no no no no
it's the government that is creating
this economic havoc and it's and it's
not just supply shortages it's rail car
shortages it's container ship shortages
it's truck driver shortages it's natural
raw supply shortages i mean these
shortages are a lot more significant i
do think they're deliberate i do think
they're going to try to uh launch
another economic war on people the
lockdowns were economic war they
destroyed small businesses they helped
the billionaire class but but by and
large the psychological warfare aspect
the trauma put on people was far higher
far more significant and i think we have
to kind of reevaluate where we are as a
people because we can make fun of people
who wear masks we could you know some
people call them mask tards whatever but
these are people who are hurt these are
people who are traumatized and i think
trying to reach out to them in an
empathetic way trying to reach out to
them and make them understand like hey
hey it's okay let's let's actually have
a rational real conversation that's not
based on emotion but based on facts
let's actually show the data let's
actually have this conversation and we
can't even do that on big tech social
media because they're blocking a lot of
the conversations and that's why you
know alternatives are so important you
have your your own uh platform tim
that's growing i have mine i know you're
working on yours uh you you probably
have your own website as well i
definitely recommend building that up
focusing on your email list not on
social media but but james i kind of i
kind of wanted to bring it back because
you talked about telegram a little bit
you're banned from twitter what
alternatives are you seeing as the most
ones that have the most amount of people
yeah that you reach
and we're at half a million email subs
and now we're like at a million
so so that's like outra it's like not
even exponential is an understatement so
so people if you build it they will come
yeah can i ask you what service you use
or what service you recommend i don't
know if you guys are privy to that i
don't know if you guys can
campaign monitor okay um uh if you build
it they will come when you start
starting your career i admired your your
um your moxie you just went out there
and did it you you went there to borrow
shane smith's uh
uh
we go there advice imagine how
ridiculous he is your unique value
proposition is actually going to the
destination you're reporting on but
that's what you did and um uh to borrow
your
metaphor about war uh the war is here
there's a great movie called the insider
which if you haven't seen it you should
watch it with al pacino and it was about
the whistleblower in 1996 on 60 minutes
who blew the whistle on big tobacco and
uh the attorney the attorney hired by
the state of mississippi to assist in
suing big tobacco explains so eloquently
that in combat events have a duration of
seconds sometimes minutes
but what what what you go through in
this country if you're a whistleblower
goes in day in day out week in week out
month after month you're assaulted
psychologically yeah you're assaulted
financially which is its own special
kind of violence because it's directed
at your children
you feel your whole family's future
compromised held hostage
this is war
yes it is and on this in this country
traditionally
you hardly ever see these things happen
i mean jeffrey weigam was a hero he blew
the whistle on big tobacco the nicotine
was addictive
but what i'm seeing from my perspective
in terms of whether it's whatever
platform you're on
i'm seeing people willing to go to war
this woman inside pfizer
i looked into her eyes yeah okay i sat
across from her and she said
i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm going to expose these people aren't
you afraid no i'm taking a leap of faith
and she told me there's so many other
people that are willing to be assaulted
psychologically financially
that's a pretty significant thing and i
would submit to you that there's two
types of courage to fight a war
um i i've never done what you've done
and i admire your courage because i
don't have your courage it basically
comes down to eating crayons and
things like that but there's different
types of courage there's moral courage
which means you're going up and you
don't know what's going to happen to you
yes and i think that i'm just seeing i'm
i'm seeing the landscape and i'm seeing
a lot of people
willing to say
i value the public's right to know above
my own welfare and my own career and my
own livelihood and i also have children
and i don't know how i'm going to feed
them
but the public's right to know is so
paramount and i just think that that is
a very beautiful phenomenon and i think
you're going to see a lot of people come
in from the federal government on the
record sitting down talking violating
their own non-disclosure agreements
that's a significant thing and one could
argue perhaps
um
that that's war you you brought up they
have children they're not gonna don't
know how they're going to feed them and
that's one big debate we had on this
show that people are saying i can't just
put my politics before my children
because i need to make sure they're well
fed but i would would assert the only
reason your kids are struggling to get
food now or there's a risk is because of
compliance
when they started the fir the first part
of the lockdowns we all complied and
that was reasonable for a regular person
then they've exacerbated those lockdowns
they've gotten worse it's been nearly
two years and they're still here they're
still locking everything down and people
still comply the shortages are due to
the economic shutdown your children are
at risk of not having food because you
complied with the edicts that are not
constitutional that are not legal
and so now to hear people are saying i'm
willing to go to war i'll put it this
way i just mentioned that when people
have no risk their risk of losing their
shelter they have no bodily security and
they have no food they have nothing left
to lose
now you're seeing all these people maybe
one of the reason you're seeing so many
people is because they've been beaten
down so much they're like it's it's it's
the line for me
i cannot go any further james here's the
documents there's going to be despair
before there is hope you're going to be
pushed to the precipice i feel like this
is a very american thing that occurs
you're pushed to the line and then
everyone's okay
with this it's uncomfortable i'm pushing
back yeah and i've been doing like i
said for a decade maybe you get one or
two sources a year not 10 000 in in in
two weeks where can people email you if
they've they've got veritas tips at
protonmail.com that's v e r i t a s tips
at protonmail.com in fact david johnson
the um uh who messaged me here a moment
ago david johnson was the guy of the
critical race theory inside hasbro toys
was inspired by you tim oh wow he loves
you and your show and cool glad to hear
it he came to us via me being here so i
would encourage you to message me and um
we have a lot of people inside
multiple people inside pfizer
a lot of people on the border patrol
a lot of people on customs and border
patrol and of course the fbi is
listening so
good for you but
uh we have um
the fbi they become i'm just going to
say it on the record you become a
weaponized intelligence operation used
to be a law enforcement operation but
you've become a weaponized in domestic
intelligence operation
uh and um you know if uh you come after
me i don't break the law so if you come
after me uh uh
the rank and file inside your
organization will hopefully revolt
because it's horrible and uh but a lot
of people and customs of border patrol a
lot of people on the board are reaching
out to us many of those people will go
public remember how fun x-files was yeah
it looked so cool you know mulder was
kind of crazy but it was still like
it was still cool
now i'm just like
what are they going after like pull
ropes and garages and where are the
agents with the stones
because
god bless your brothers and sisters in
battle overseas but where are the people
with the stones inside the bureau well
and that thing is is a lot of those guys
were the same guys that were overseas a
lot of those guys in
ibm one of them thank god i didn't get
into the fbi when i applied because i
failed a polygraph test because of my
former use of cannabis but i'm telling
you right now like to think that the
the fbi can't just roll up a lot of
these politicians and asshats who are
running around in corporate america or
the banksters like this is a slam dunk
and we're not oh and we don't have any
anybody from the upper echelons ever
seeing justice are you i mean i think
people are sick of that they enter
congress at 174 000 a year salary and
then after you know a couple decades
they're worth hundreds of millions or
whatever and they wear lizard suits but
you think the ranking file
the rank and file these organizations
are probably decent good people i would
think well and the thing is like i know
these guys i mean i can i can go to
their house here and that's the thing is
like hey what the hell is going on and
i've heard some chatter you know behind
the scenes and all that kind of stuff
but it's just like at the end of the day
i don't see anything i don't see
anything rolled up before a judge i
definitely don't see anything before
cameras and i don't see anything for
people who are waiting like normal
regular everyday people who are sitting
there going like listen we know jeffrey
epstein didn't kill himself
have we done any investigation into this
kind of stuff where is just lane maxwell
where is she you know why are we not
talking about this kind of stuff can
people
the challenges we don't know
however my favorite quote is when i
think it was chris reagan got into an
uber
and uber driver immediately goes yo that
guy didn't kill himself
nobody believes the official narrative
on this well i will tell you one quick
story about the fbi um happened in april
this year the new york times had a front
page hit piece on me so i was trying to
subvert the fbi subvert the fbi because
project veritas because we did some
investigative reporting on on people in
dc at bars making comments about how
they weren't working the people work for
the state department they worked for the
doj one of them was an assistant they
were all fired from their jobs they
didn't report that part that they were
fired from their jobs for doing bad
things no they said i was trying to
support the fbi
and and right when that new york times
story broke the atf the alcohol tobacco
and firearms called my cell phone at
first i thought it was a prank call i
thought this was a bad lauren windsor
ryan clayton operator we'd like to tell
you about your vehicles
this can't possibly be an atf agent from
albany new york it's
it's
an snl skit of what an atf no no they
were calling me saying did you buy a
shotgun last year
and i did and it's legal for me to do so
and as a new york state resident buy a
shotgun
and i said what are you talking about
are you kidding me i said i'm going to
put you in touch with my my lawyer
because i don't know why you're calling
me and they said well do you have
something to be ashamed of and i'm like
what
i literally was was shocked and this
happened right when the new york times
published their article
so the new york times and the fbi and
the atf are all just working together
yeah
it's just
it's a comedy of errors it's dystopian
it's anti-anathema to everything that
journalism is supposed to be but i have
to believe the rank and file
that the the so-called middle class
of these organizations are good people
and there's going to be a point of no
return a event horizon where those
people say to hell with this you can put
me in jail i'm ready to go to jail
because i want to stand in principle or
something's more important
than than being part of this institution
i mean that's very optimistic i would
definitely disagree especially from our
history context which believing that the
agency's going to turn for the greater
good i hope so i wish i we should always
try we should always put everything in
our ability to make sure that this
happens but this is also the same agency
that literally sat on their hands for
over 30 years as as epstein was able to
run into i don't think they're going to
traffic i don't think they're going to
turn i think that people are probably
going to go public yeah with revelations
i hope so uh some of them are uh some of
them are just being fired some of them
are quitting as well so it's a very very
difficult dichotomy to be in but even
from the history of the fbi i mean
there's so many instances now okay right
right yeah mlk from the very beginning
uh jfk2 but but as they're hassling you
there's literal people who hurt children
in unspeakable ways that the fbi just
decides to oh nasty look the other way
nassar epstein we could keep going
andrew now they're talking about they
might not even charge the guy what is
that yeah yeah they
and the victims are like they are
deliberately making sure that we get no
justice here at all so there's something
sinister to the core of these agencies
that really deserves to be called out
because again they're unaccountable and
and they're essentially they had victims
coming from jeffrey epstein in the 90s
to the fbi the fbi recorded witness
testimony about epstein from the 90s and
they still didn't do anything
i wanted to ask you uh james yeah how
long have you been doing this work
well since i was 19 when i started my
college newspaper and pretty much have
been doing it ever since then it broke
through in a major way when i was 24
years old so since about 2004. you've
been putting yourself out there you know
you you yourself are exposed you've had
like the government come after you on
more than one occasion oh yeah i was
arrested by the fbi in 2010 i was
falsely accused of a felony which i was
eventually exonerated from but it was a
whole i wrote a whole book about it was
a long story you've been very brave
and with uh that courage you've inspired
many others to be brave to come forward
to stand up reject the authoritarianism
the lies the manipulation
and so when i hear from a lot of people
saying
they say oh it's easy for you to say tim
look how well off you are my point is
i have lived a life of willing to stand
up and say no when when i am faced with
something i view as wrong
and that has not led me astray and i
feel the same for you you have
repeatedly stood up defended what's
right even with the federal government
coming after you and getting arrested by
the fbi you refuse to back down and it's
worked out pretty well for you and even
helped you lead many others from that i
would just say to many other people
don't look at any of us and think that
we have any excuse or that it's easier
for us it was it was years of risk and
sacrifice and i think that's why it's
it's so incredible when you do these
these these fundraisers for the
whistleblowers
that you're you're basically i don't
know there's a safety net there yeah you
can be brave we're not gonna let you
down it isn't it is not that you are
going to come out stand up for what you
believe in and you will be thrown to the
wind well i think um this is uh
this is very important thing to say is
that the things i've been through i
don't i mean i i when i was
incarcerated and and then placed on
federal probation supervised probation
it was this very bizarre thing i went
through and it was so bizarre that my
lawyers and i've never seen anything
like this before so it was a political
prisoner and i and i had this sort of
why have you forsaken me
thing for two or three years in new
jersey i was stuck
in a like a halfway house situation it's
like what is this is to be falsely
accused of something
and to be
jailed for it is a really terrifying
experience when you grow up to pledge
allegiance to your flag
and i said why am i going through this
and i did not know why until
recently
a lot of the people
trust project veritas because of the
things that i have been through
because i guess it shows them that you
know i believe in what i'm doing
but i also think that
the facts disclosed in these reports
brought into the
consciousness of ordinary people
tends to expand
tend to expand the audience and you you
create this effect where the balance of
political forces
starts to change and the role of the
oppressor
becomes reversed and and uh as david
assumes new strength goliath
starts to be attacked from all sides
the hunter becomes the hunted the the
the organizations in question probably
fear
um i think this is a safe and my team is
over there i'm going to ask a rhetorical
question
i think it's safe to assume they fear us
more than we fear them at this point in
time and the one thing i've learned
about communism because i've been
fascinated by con i'm reading a lot
about communism it strikes me that the
only thing i think this is a great issue
to ask you the only thing they fear
at this point in time is being exposed
i'm not sure they fear anything else do
they
they fear anything else if the uh i i
would say mostly i agree with you like
maybe we'd have to research a little bit
more to think about it or think about a
little bit more but i think
so long as people are kept in the dark
they can do whatever they want
their whole agenda hangs in the balance
of lies that could be exposed at any
moment so that's a very delicate
vulnerable situation to be in and i
wouldn't want to be in that situation
i feel like shows like this
um and the work you do they certainly
have done they've done a lot to try and
silence you and it's not working and i
think that's that's exactly why a lot of
people might say okay well if they're
really all powerful or if they're really
this big coordinated group or there's
powerful elites like why aren't they
just banning all these channels they're
not that powerful there's powerful
interests and powerful elites and they
are fighting a war and they need you
convinced that they own you they control
you you can't do anything no but the
people actually have the ability i think
your proof i think this show right now
is proof i'm sure there's a lot of
people over at youtube who are watching
this going like oh geez hey tim i'm sure
there's a lot of people at youtube who
who like you i know that's true
i don't know what percentage fifteen
twenty percent well i'll i'll let you
i'll tell you guys um i know uh i've
known for a long time some people at
google have actually consulted some of
the development of you know various apps
they've been trying to do particularly
on live streaming and mobile stuff and
i've hung out at the google hq several
times i've invited all these youtube
parties and now it's it's not the same
in the past few years things have
definitely been different
but i i talked to some of my uh friends
who have since left youtube and they'll
say things to me like oh dude there's a
ton of people at youtube who are like
watching us all the time they're huge
fans i hear from current workers they're
like yeah we actually really enjoy your
content we don't you know it's you know
uh the interesting thing is they all
feel like they can't say anything and
has to be a secret they're like oh but
no one no one can know we watch your
show
that's the scary thing they need you
convinced that you can't express
yourself
and and
you can the the look what you were
saying about when you when you just
finally stopped caring what people think
about you is when you'll be free
there was this thing i was reading today
about a paradox where people go along
with something they hate because they
think everyone else likes it but
everyone else hates it too so it
enforces this social you know order over
suffering
there are a lot of people probably at a
lot of companies you wouldn't expect
they're probably big fans of you james
they're big fans of luke big fans of you
shane
they won't say it though out of fear and
that's why i always say
you've got to stand up for yourself
you've got to speak up for these things
because it lets other people know you're
lighting that torch in the cave then
everyone can finally see andrew
breitbart used to say something to the
effect of um um if you keep going you're
sending a message to others that they
can you know keep going keep running
towards the fire but just imagine if all
the people just stood up with cameras
and exposed all the deceivers in the
midst and that i think you'd be out of a
job
no i mean
that is that is the mission of of of
what we're trying to accomplish a good
non-profit should shut itself down that
is absolutely true i don't think i'll
ever be out of a job but yes
so much there's too much corruption i
think people are going to be afraid
though of the person sitting next to
them wearing a camera and that'll
that'll create a more virtuous society
bro i gotta tell you you know i watch
the work you do and sometimes it feels
like you are sitting at the base of the
burj dubai with a ball-peen hammer
trying to knock it down
there is just so much corruption but
maybe that's unfair because i think
you've had such a tremendous impact with
many of these stories that's why it's so
viral that's why it's been expanded but
no one does any no one's done any favors
like there's no i have no i have no real
allies in in a sense i mean even even
the the story on uh ivory hecker who is
a fox
uh fox news organization local affiliate
but i noticed that fox was wary to have
me on after that story so i don't really
have any allies no one's done any favors
every story has to be so strong and so
bulletproof and so incontrovertible that
it forces people to share it even though
we're banned on twitter
you know and you're right nonprofits
most start you know eric hoffers dictate
what started out as a mass movement
usually ends up as a racket a cult or a
corporation so most non-profit
organizations in dc have a stated
mission and if you solve the problem
they can no longer fundraise
i think the larger point that i think
we're trying to get at here and trying
to tell the audience is that living a
life with fear is a life not worth
living
what's the point if you're gonna be
scared
and and not be able to live your truest
freest version and once you let go of
those shackles that kind of mind control
that controls every aspect of your
existence your life becomes amazing it
becomes beautiful and it becomes so much
more fun and so much more worthwhile
than being a wagey than being someone
that is licking someone's jack boots
complying and afraid that someone might
actually
get them sick or might take away their
money once you get rid of all that fear
everything
i believe in some you know synchronicity
as well everything kind of lines up
through the trajectory of your existence
and it lines up perfectly once you let
go of that fear and you start going
towards uh you know i don't want to
sound like a damn hippie love but but
it's true
but it's true it's true there's these
two major frequencies you choose which
ones you resonate with and once you let
go of that negative one once you're in
that positive pathway everything just
starts opening up for you i'm wearing
that crystal and the other you know
it's a nice positive crystal but the
other like to your point it's not even
just not living in fear it's
seeing the fear and realizing the fear
and taking action in face of that fear
and that's courage i mean we need a lot
more people that will sit there and say
listen i understand the risk these are
great risks to me my family my health
you know maybe even just being on this
earth anymore and saying you know what i
got to do the right thing here some
things are more important that what you
said there was it was so eloquent i
almost feel like my team should to
should cut that as an ad for being a
project veritas whistleblower you're
right
uh that the the the need to not live in
fear is is liberating even if you lose
everything and and i've come to peace
with the fact that i may go back to jail
uh
not because i've done anything illegal
but because i haven't done anything
illegal i've i've just come to peace
with that because i'd rather do the
right thing and i can live with myself
and my conscience can be clean and
there's you know if you're an odds maker
you might even say it's probable maybe
maybe political prison
political prison jail you know gulags
potato potato
yeah quarantine center let's jump over
to super chats we gotta we got a ton of
super chats i don't think we'll get to
ever we're not gonna be able to get
everybody but we'll read as much as we
can smash that like button many of you
already have and go to timcast.com
because we'll have that member segment
coming up on 11 or so pm let's read
this one is is important waffle sensei
says my facebook was suspended today for
sharing the project veritas story on
pfizer it was memory hold and i was
threatened by facebook that if i repost
it they would take further punitive
action against my account
that is happening everywhere what do we
think about that eric
i mean i think it's just getting worse i
mean we've probably seen tens of
thousands tens of thousands of messages
facebook's really coming at us instagram
hasn't taken down the recent videos
youtube still has it up
facebook's really really butt hurt and
they're gonna die because of it though
yeah they're gonna lose people are
leaving they're gonna they're true
that's that's the thing we've gained 500
000 email addresses so let them let them
eat cake to quote marie antoinette let
them let them do their thing and veritas
will just become a mass movement you can
all revel in the idea that i think what
zuckerberg lost a couple billion at
least the other day right and he's not
it's not going gonna get any better
yes yes and yes that's that's right
dylan tooley says i live in la i feel
lost and don't know what to do after
these vax requirements i'm another
problem vax anti-mandator now what would
you guys say to somebody live in los
angeles right now they just enacted the
strictest vaccine mandates my personal
thing is move
it may not be easy it may be the hardest
thing you've ever done in your life you
got to get out
either way i mean either stand your
ground and and don't comply i mean mass
disobedience is what america needs more
than ever right now and peaceful right
like i mean that's it's one of the core
principles that i talk about is just
peace speaking of mass civil
disobedience tim uh this just happened
twitter
is labeling the give sengo that's the
christian website to fundraise for the
whistleblowers give send go give
sendgo.com backslash pfizer
whistleblower twitter has sent out a
message to anyone who shared this link
saying quote warning this link may be
unsafe
wow the link is unsafe they're coming up
with new there's like graphic designers
at twitter designing new you know
things to post i got one today that said
this conversation might be intense
somebody photo shot it and said it
online malicious links violent
violent links
that so so the fundraising website for
the fisa whistleblower for quoting the
vice president pfizer is quote possibly
violent so here's what i want i'm going
to do a call to action here we're going
to show these people who's boss um
there's a quarter million people
watching this live stream if all of you
donated five dollars
to melissa at give sengo backslash
uh gibson go backslash pfizer
whistleblower that's p f i z er
whistleblower that's give sengo
backslash buys a whistleblower you tell
jax dorsey who's boss
because they just sent out a message
saying that the fundraising website was
unsafe
unsafe
that's how they do it
all right ah incredible we got jeremy
conrad who says first super chat ever
does james have any suggestions on how
to be an investigative journalist and
what can i do as an individual to fight
what's happening school of hard knocks
people people ask me how did i learn to
sail my sailboat i said school of hard
knocks just go out there and fail you
gotta go out there and stumble and fail
a couple rules about journalism uh
publish something that the person
doesn't want published everything else
is public relation so there's some
element of secrecy
they're trying to keep secret hidden
from the public that's the that's a good
story uh if i was in college start when
you're in college especially at a state
university which is you know governed by
foia requests i went to rutgers it was a
public school and and get your get your
feet wet in college and go out there and
just start doing it go out in the street
hidden cameras in in 38 states is legal
you got to just go out there and do it
tim and learn the hard way
right on here's one uh wreath nelson
says father of four and refuse the jab
will not teach them submission sold off
almost all of my world war one and world
war ii collection to start my own
machine shop but need help
site give save go under stand alone
okay best of luck and i mean that
sincerely and that and and uh wreath
says give save go quote stand alone uh i
i genuinely give send go
it says quote give save go maybe humans
give sengo i think maybe
that's that's uh seems highly probable
but to everybody who's taking that risk
um like i said maybe the hardest thing
you do in your life i get it but
i just feel like compliance will make
things worse you will not you you cannot
comply your way out of tyranny
true statement and if you got not i mean
that's the thing is if you just got
enough people to sit there saying no
what they're doing right now at these
major companies where the mandates came
out is they're taking polls they're
saying hey are you vaccinated or you're
not vaccinated if you say listen i'm not
telling you and i'm going to ask for my
reasonable request here to say you don't
have any grounds to ask me on this and
then start citing law on top of it man
enough of those people and the company
changes their mind right there
there was actually a story we had um
that i think we're looking into they
said something like there were six
thousand employees their company and
three thousand rejected the mandate so
the company just shut up yeah because
they were like well we want we like
existing so we'll do what the people say
how you do it
frosty guns says tim your talk about
vaccine medics has spoken to me my
college is requiring them now and so
after this term i'm quitting everything
i know to go to florida long live the
republic tim thank you
well
i'll say this i think college is a waste
of time
yeah i don't think you said school of
hard knocks i agree
i spent depends on what he wants to do
right
a lawyer or a doctor i always take the
money from college and start a business
probably the best thing for you yeah
yeah
you can always take the money uh from
college use it to live off of where you
do a an internship to learn the ropes
and watch something and then have a
better chance of doing your own thing
what are you passionate about i mean if
you're going to college and you don't
know what the hell you're going to do
anyway you're wasting your time which is
your most valuable and your money and
then money on top of it when you're
going to go into debt which you could
probably pay for business house or
business business loans are a lot more
forgiving than college
all right we got a bunch of
recommendations for various people we'll
definitely look into
let's see
macaroni says thanks for the email from
project veritas share by proxy youtube
didn't notify me of the stream
yeah and i'm kind of feeling like um
we've had a few guests that youtube
clearly wasn't recommending and like our
viewership was way low and i'm wondering
if your guys share by proxy is helping
keep keep people notified that we're
having the show you know what i mean
you guys send out an email i suppose so
and that's probably it
all right let's see we got here
scott spivey says tim facebook banned
pfizer veritas video i posted today so i
posted your tim cast news video on the
subject today and they struck that down
and gave me a warning
that's amazing can't get it out man
can't let it out of the bag it was funny
zuckerberg actually expressed uh some
made a statement on an executive zoom
call about his opinion about the facts
he was concerned about its effects on
dna rna and mark zuckerberg's own
statement privately to his fellow
executives on this private zoom call
which was linked to us would be in
violation of the facebook policy me
quoting mark zuckerberg would get me
banned on facebook so it's a comedy of
errors it's a dystopian you know reality
it's great that we're laughing about it
it's weird that the android has feelings
too right
we'll all be in jail soon but it'll be
fine we'll have a great job
bokeh trent sink says andrew breitbart
would be proud of you james thank you
for what you do for freedom of
information and saving the world to that
no i missed the man he was he was a
force of nature there's no one like him
you know what's really crazy is um i
know this like ridiculously liberal
woman who is just like she was
russiagate insane and she knew andrew
back in the day and i remember us having
lunch with her and she was talking to me
because she was lefty back then she was
like i don't know what happened to him
he used to be such a good liberal and
then one day he started to change and
then he just became far right and this
is this was this was a long time ago
long time ago i was told this this is
probably like
2011 no no this is 2009 2010 maybe i was
told this way back late 2010
i think it was
that was i was told this and i always
thought it was really interesting well
breitbart was a was a very unique man it
was a different world
uh back back then i mean when people
would engage with each other like you
know dave weigel the washington post you
would you would engage with each other
on twitter now it's just this
such dichotomous polarized society where
you we are starting at 5 million views
on youtube and not one single blue check
mark person will even utter a word about
it
nine years ago and andrew and i were
working together it was just different
and right before he died like three days
for andrew died march 1st 2012 i
remember the morning
he made this statement to me on the
telephone it was something something
like james they want us to dance we're
not going to dance with them they want
us on a leash they want us to be leased
we're not going to be leashed you know
we're going to it was just he had this
very prophetic powerful cultural warrior
spirit
and and he knew andrew breitbart knew
how to
not how to work with the media but also
exposed the media was this this this
ballet he did where he sort of hacked
the media but those were the days a
decade ago when you when when there was
conversation 10 years ago
even though they hated me they'd still
talk to me
john stewart praised you on multiple
occasions he did he don stewart was 75
percent you know
you know he had this 25 75 whereas
trevor noah is just a hundred to zero
but it was a different world it was just
a different time and it was it was much
more interesting it's sad that uh
people won't know that uh part of the
world but that's what it was ten years
that's when they didn't think they could
say the uh the private things out loud
and now they don't care right
right yeah jason cudu says james is
absolutely right journalists headlines
reporting on articles these days are
wordsmith professionals more than just
spin unbelievable how disingenuous it is
it is it is sometimes i read these
articles and i'm just flabbergasted
you know the the the fascist union
workers
helped by rupert murdoch has to be one
of the most psychotic headlines i've
ever seen
are there people who still fall for this
stuff of course that's crazy when you
lock people down and you keep them
isolated which is a
you know an absolute torture tactic to
make people mentally unstable of course
they believe this kind of stuff stop
watching mainstream propaganda turn it
off if you haven't done it turn it off
now well they tend to these reporters
tend to extol the high and mighty rather
than expose them
and in this and then this symbiotic
relationship between quote-unquote
journalists i say that in quotes and the
pharmaceutical companies in the
government it's usually the one in the
pharmaceutical company manipulating the
journalists
it's usually the it's usually
the one in the corporation the
government is doing the manipulating so
like a two-star general anonymously
talks to the new york times the new york
times report is the one being
manipulated by their source
and what we do is unmask those sources
we don't care uh so that's the problem
the problem in the there becomes slaves
to access tim media has become slave to
their dependency on their sources of
information it's it's amazing how
earning credibility in journalism is how
how you can climb the the establishment
social letter you know you you work for
a news organization and you get access
to you know saki or someone in the band
administration yeah you get the story ah
joe biden told me this that's right then
you can publish the story like oh good
job what's the john taylor gatto the you
know the school teacher from new york
that wrote a whole bunch of great books
on the indoctrination of america and
where it came from with prussia right
when you look at the regurgitation
that's taught just hey just regurgitate
what we're talking about and you'll be
fine manufacturing consent is also a
great book that i recommend people read
great book
all right into the fray podcast says for
james thank you for what you do question
what are your thoughts on a movement to
encourage states take a stand and
protect their citizens from these
illegal and immoral exercises of federal
power
as such a movement exists i think it's
called um uh i forgot the name of the
organization that does that very thing
i've um i've just escaped my mind but uh
there is an organization that does that
if it comes to me i'll bring it up again
right on phoenix on says tim is right it
makes no difference if your vax passport
says vaccinated or natural immunity it's
the passport that's the problem
because once they have that they can add
whatever they want to it they can be
like you got to be six feet tall sorry
bye-bye wow
i mean obviously they i doubt they do
something like that but you get the
point they can put whatever
nick um mkhanji says thank you for your
amazing work project veritos
veritas but you know worth reading
veritas it's getting late on thursday
project varieties the irs no the irs
stamped our approval in 2011 right when
the lois lerner was you know going after
the tea party and i got to think because
my name wasn't on the documents i wasn't
on the board then
i got to think that she thought she was
stamping like a latin book discussion
club or something she had no idea what
she was approving
put it in front of her kcb says i sold
my beautiful house in the city and got a
farmhouse on a bit of land i deleted all
social media and spend my time attending
it never been happier nice awesome every
every day i wake up
i you know do my morning you know
routine hygiene have some coffee and
then i get to work you know i'm reading
as soon as i wake up i'm like reading
news stories i've got messages from
people and i'm going through it but as
soon as i finish my first recording i go
ten to the chickens we've got 15 now
and we've got the babies are separated
from the adults and you got to do all
the work and then after i do that i get
back to work and so then there's
meetings and then there's plans there's
projects it is endless work all day and
then i get maybe from like
3 p.m to 4 i get to exercise i'll be
skating then i get to eat food uh today
we had to go to the store today because
we ran out of food and then it's back to
work back to work because we have this
show and guests are coming and we're
doing a whole bunch of shows it's just
endless work but i'll tell you this
going outside and one of the one of the
best days best morning i've ever had was
when i got my own eggs right from the
chickens i picked some peppers right
from the front from the little farm area
grabbed a handful of cherry tomatoes i
went inside chopped it all up made some
made an omelette
all from my own food it's a crazy
feeling growing up in the city a lot of
people in the city they've never
experienced them like this they don't
understand you just pick the egg up you
just eat it it's independence too yeah
and it came from almost nothing
that i mean and i gotta wish america was
there i'm a homesteader in in georgia
and it's like to be able to do all this
with your own life and your own property
i
if i didn't have to be in politics
because i want my kids to be free
someday i would spend all my time and
effort trying to make sure that people
understand that hey your your ability to
grow food provide for your own safety uh
get water and energy and all that kind
of stuff on your own man that is that is
one of those most self-fulfilling
pieces of life you could possibly have
this is interesting i see dean says
found out from a customer who works for
a big pennsylvania meatpacking plant
that the fda will shut down any facility
that does not have 100 of the employees
vaxxed it is not up to management but
the government i have not heard that
that that definitely we should
investigate and we'll look into
these nuts on your mom says
thank you for having james on when no
big media outlet will touch him right
now because it will hurt their profits
well you know look
um i'm a big fan of project veritas i i
made you guys reposted that joke i made
where i was like james has got a serious
problem he's gonna require surgery
because he has he has too many spines uh
but i'm just you know you know what
really frustrates me is if you watch the
arguments i have i'm constantly upset
with people who are cowardly people who
won't be brave who won't stand up for
themselves and then i can look over at
the project veritas team and be like
these by these they're putting
everything on the line for this like we
were talking before the show we were
like
is james scared like do you think he's
worried about i mean you mentioned
political prison
so so when i see the work you guys are
doing i'm like bro you can come on
whenever you want well that's why we you
text i get a text message in the middle
of the day and i'm like james i think
someone dm'd me yesterday from your
staff and said you want to come on
tomorrow and i got back three o'clock
this afternoon i'd say two things i
would say
um the commercial this is a guy at abc
news we secretly recorded
and he said in a bar the commercial
imperative is incompatible with the news
so it's very difficult to pursue profit
and also do it be an investigative
reporter so and traditionally what would
happen in like the 1970s or something is
that a capitalist newsman would say i'm
just going to lose money on this
investigation because i believe in the
cause of doing good news journalism that
that's gone people don't do that so you
the idea of spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars on an investigation
which is what it cost us to do but we're
a foundation we don't have advertising
dollars gives us independence
but the commercial imperative says don't
do that settle the lawsuit
so we don't settle litigation and then
and then furthermore yeah i mean fear i
mean i've already sort of talked about
that and you have to be at peace
you have to be at peace with this uh
notion that you could become a political
prisoner i'll speak from experience on
that on that part about investigative
journalism so and i'll explain to people
the formula and how it works
the people running media outlets today
are are businessmen they get venture
capital from big firms they have they
have a duty to profit and so what
happens is
someone comes along and says
ceo of company i've got this
investigation we have documents that
that lead us to believe this corporation
has done this evil thing
now we've got a whistleblower on the
record but we need to get that hard
confirmation we're going to need a small
team to do this it'll take us about a
year and the business man says really
this will be a big story oh it'll be the
biggest all right how many people do you
need well me and these two reporters you
know if i'm getting paid you know 70 000
a year and they're each getting paid you
know 50 or 60. then we're going to need
budget for travel and he's going to go
okay whoa whoa whoa we're already
talking about 200 grand what's my what's
my return on this yeah well
i don't know that's for your business to
decide can you guarantee me the story
will produce fruit no it could turn out
that we can't dig up what we did we
could we could spend a year on this and
nothing happens then all of a sudden
another person walks right up to him and
says uh hey uh i'm going to write an
article about how james o'keefe is far
right and it'll get a million clicks and
the guy goes how much do you want i
don't know a hundred dollars and he goes
how much do i make of it well a million
views i don't know and he goes done yeah
that's that's that's that's the method
right now yeah i've leaned into the most
expensive thing you could possibly do
and it's like cost me a million dollars
to a story
and i don't know how i'm going to raise
the money but we do and and there's in
these lawsuits just one more comment
about this the litigation battles i've
been through is is
it's unbelievable i
in the teeter in the tier loss it went
to federal jury trial and one federal
jury trial federal court took us three
years i could have settled the case for
i don't know 50 grand
which sounds like a lot of a lot of
money but um the the cost of the
litigation was 2 million dollars so i
effectively said
go to hell i'm not giving you 50 000.
i'm going to spend 2 million on
principal and 1. it's just unheard of i
mean and by the way that's not on my
wikipedia page that's an extraordinary
uh i think that's the most proud
achievement at project veritas we won
every lawsuit yeah think of it i mean
can you name any media corporation
that doesn't that that that doesn't
settle lawsuits and you'd think that's
an indication you're right but they
don't put those facts on our wikipedia
page they selectively edit them out they
deceptively edit them out of a wikipedia
page think of it and and um and cnn i'm
sorry the washington post set a
litigation with nick sandman that was
the young guy that was with the native
american they settled that lawsuit
why isn't that the first sentence of the
wikipedia page
they deceptively edit content frequently
and have been called out and sued for it
democracy dies in darkness they want you
to keep doing it but jeff bezos
whatever he's worth a trillion dollars
now
is his most proud achievement he wrote
on the medium his proudest achievement
was his ownership of the washington post
that's an extraordinary statement
because the washington post that woke
click bait rag cost him whatever it was
a 200 mil and he thinks that owning it
is more impressive than amazon
than than
you know is dr evil spaceship huh um
yeah i think there is an extraordinary
admission and it shows to show you how
much power the washington post has by
virtue of their relationship with google
twitter and facebook he he he's like a a
fit her doctor evil
but he kind of looks like him and he
literally made a doctor evil spaceship
looked like a doctor evil space a ship
sure
yeah johnson
that's an unverifiable expression of
opinion
[Laughter]
all right curry says p.s i love you tim
keep doing the lord's work dave smith
for president zach give him my resume
yeah dave smith uh big fans
nice great guy
all right let's see
mike roach says james i want to help
bring truth but i only have a few more
dollars than this super chat how do i
help what's a clearer answer than hard
work
would you say that again
is a clearer answer to them mike is
asking how does he help what is a
clearer answer than quote hard work a
more clear answer than heart more
specific maybe oh
you want to help well there's three
there's three things you can do you can
you can fight you can go out in the
field and and expose them you can
fund the people who do that or support
the people who do that or you can do
nothing
those are your three options
so uh think about which of those
categories you wanna and you can donate
five dollars to this whistleblower uh
that's something you can do i'm sure
that's something you can afford to do
uh so i would say you can work for
project veritas we have a we have a
website projectveritas.com we have
applications for employment
it depends upon what your passion is and
what your skill set is
this is interesting uh z dowd says some
meds that used fetal cell lines during
rnd acetaminophen aspirin ibuprofen
tylenol pepto-bismol tums lipitor motrin
x-lax benadryl sudafed preparation h and
claritin now i can't confirm any of
those but um i have heard that many of
these modern medications people don't
realize used fetal cell lines and i
would submit to you that if the
executives at peptobismal if i had
emails saying we need to keep this
secret from our consumers that i would
report that story just like this one and
i think that it's the politicization the
the the obsession with which side you're
on i'm going to expose all the fraud and
the deception even at tylenol if i need
to i remember i was talking to my mom
and she was like you make a lot of
videos about democrats and i was like
why did the republicans do something i
missed
and she's like well no it's always about
democrats and i was like
well if you got something let me know i
mean because i'll complain about mitch
mcconnell and lindsey graham all day but
they kind of just sit on their hands
yeah they talk tough in uh years where
they're not in power and then they get
impacted but even even in 2016 2016 16
17 18 like they didn't do anything well
that's when they were in power they
can't they don't do anything with their
power i'm like what am i complaining
about that they're they're they're
garbage politicians who do nothing the
republican party is weak and feckless
the democrats are are constantly
demanding they ban everybody's guns
they're at war man and that's the thing
they're serious whereas the republicans
aren't
so i'm not i'm not i'm not sitting here
to be like i'm gonna have a free pass to
republicans i don't agree with their
policies but i'll tell you this it's
really easy to get conservatives to come
and hang out and discuss their political
beliefs i can sit down with glenn beck
and we can debate you know pro-life
versus pro-choice shake our hands smile
and have tremendous respect for each
other i don't get that from the left
they they're mostly terrified to come
and talk about these politic political
ideas well there's no principle and and
the thing is
if you have to result to you're racist
you're a sexist you're a homophobe in
any argument that you're ever in i mean
that trope is dead these days
thank god
all right let's see
free men die free says vote libertarian
lpmc at the minimum if uh in your state
government if you won't do it federally
do so at state level
i'm actually a big fan of that um but i
think the libertarian party is too wacky
to be honest well the mises caucus
yeah so the national definitely is
like nobody in the libertarian party is
a big well i say nobody most people in
the libertarian party aren't fans of
national i mean right now there is a
concerted effort that will probably go
through this next year where the lpmc is
going to go in and clean house at the
national level and i think the lpmc i
mean i'm part of it myself it is it is
one of these
organizations thanks to like mike heiss
and dave smith and the rest of these
guys that are done playing nice and
going out and fighting instead of you
know kind of taking these positions
where they want to be liked by the left
or the right in mainstream media it's
amazing i'm going to do a quick quick
fact check on one of these super chats
real quick
um
let me just check something real quick i
okay uh-oh
maybe at the time of the super chat
but
let me see
i'm looking at twitter trends right now
i don't see it
i see glenn greenwald is trending
and ben shapiro well someone said you
are top trending on twitter again i had
to get your attention about it veritas
or you veritas ah yeah jonathan
galterini said that
well
the problem is that super chat came in a
while we were trending uh exposed
twitter was trending here today uh 50
000 tweets
um i was trending under enter the
entertainment section
james o'keefe was trying to under
entertain so we keep trending on twitter
even though i'm banned from twitter and
i'm suing twitter for defamation
you're doing something right
all right let's see the drunk
conservative says james keeps smashing
the oligarchy everyone needs to be just
as brave do something and have this
crazy multi-spine condition that you
have p.s let's go brandon
let's go brandon
i i
i think um
i think you have to let go of your fear
luke said that so eloquently and what
what you said i don't know how you said
that but i'm going to take a look at
that 30 i don't remember i forgot
i just blanked out that was that was a
really poetic way of saying that you're
liberated you're you're there's more to
life than obsessing over being having
approval it's also psychological this is
not a political issue it's a
psychological when people ask what can i
do what they're really asking
is um is is you know meaning it's kind
of the pursuit of happiness versus the
pursuit of meaning the pursuit of
comfort you're going to be uncomfortable
you're going to suffer you're going if
you do this you will suffer people say
what can i do well welcome to suffering
because in the journalism business
you're going to suffer you're going to
go through pain
but you're also going to have meaning in
your life and uh i think people have
arrived at that destination now and
i've had many people in the military
tell me that our war is here like you've
said today our war is not overseas it is
on our soil we we've all seen the matrix
i take it right yeah yeah
how do you feel about that guy i think
was his name cipher he was the guy who
secretly why did i take the blue pill
exactly he's the guy who secretly met
with the agents because he wanted to be
put back in the matrix
how do we feel about that guy
well i mean we don't we don't like him i
think it's what you're talking about
it's like taking action at the end of
the day in face of your fear and finding
passion and finding something to really
live for and believe in and you know at
the end of the day you can you can at
least lay your head down and sleep well
well i i bring up this character because
you know all these characters are woken
up to how the real world is they were in
the soft comfort of the matrix living a
lie with the blue pill right this guy
eventually says i don't want to live
this way it's too hard put me back in
the machine and you know what ignorance
is bliss
and that's the reality when you wake up
to what's going on whatever whatever
euphemism or whatever you want to call
it red pill or you know whatever
there's going to be a lot of struggle
yes you are you are going to take charge
of your life you are going to take risks
and it will be a struggle but for me i
would not want to be in the matrix
if you survive this abuse the the as a
muckraker over time i think you develop
a new kind of superpower just like any
survivor of any form of abuse you are no
longer a slave to fear you're
invigorated by not the knowledge that
you're no longer a slave to fear and and
suffering too can make you a a better
version of yourself
so you're right tim i think it is like
the matrix i think it's easy to comply i
have a one of my close friends is
he's the sort of guy that believes he's
my friend you believe it or not these
people people's friendships are ruined
by this day and age but my i still
maintain a very close friend who
believes what he sees on cnn and he got
his vaccines he i got my booster shot i
got my second booster shot they just
love the compliance they it it makes
them feel safe yeah it makes them feel
happy ignorance is bliss right yep
compliance is easy well my friends go to
timcast.com become a member because we
will have a members only segment coming
up around 11 or so p.m and don't forget
to smash the like button here you can
follow me at tim cast you can follow the
show at tim cast irl share the show with
your friends
if ever it's like what james saying um
you know if everybody is sharing then we
have more marketing power than cnn could
ever dream of so if every single person
right now shared this show it would it
would reach everybody okay figuratively
but um before we go james did you want
to shout anything out i think you got a
new book right yeah the book's called
american muckraker it's not out till
january but it's on pre-order now on
bezos's website amazon bezos thinks his
ownership the washington post is more
interesting that's interesting but by
the book american muckraker all proceeds
go to project veritas and of course if
you're on the inside and you're seeing
theft fraud or deception contact us at
veritastipsprotonmail.com we'll send you
a hidden camera and make your colleagues
and supervisors internet celebrities
veritas tips at protonmail.com
did you want to show anything sure yeah
radicalpod.com is my show it's where
you'll find all the links uh shane t
hazel on twitter and i'll tell you we're
going to do some very interesting things
for this governor election down here in
georgia so if you guys want to follow
that uh get involved we're going to do
some things a little bit differently in
terms of funding because
let's face it you know being bought and
paid for is kind of a cliche thing these
days we're going to do self-funding so
to help me divorce myself from
everything else
you can find the the donations and the
patreon accounts there on radicalpod.com
uh let's also not forget when you let go
of fear you have a lot more fun and you
have a lot more meaning i also wanted to
add that to the bait shouts out to ian
he's not here but if you want to follow
him you can at ian crossland my website
that i have way too much fun on is luke
uncensored.com lukeuncensored.com
we just released members only
merchandise and t-shirts available only
on luke uncensored.com hope to see you
there later on today awesome i'm gonna
have to check out lukeuncensor.com now
thank you guys for tuning in tonight
thank you all for your super chats i
know we weren't able to get to
everything but we really appreciate it
and i know really glad that project
veritas was able to get their message
out a little bit and shane was able to
get his message out too about running in
georgia you guys are welcome to follow
me on twitter at sourpatchlids we will
see all of you over at timcast.com and
the members segment thanks for hanging
out
you